hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about php and mongodb but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's session
first we will start off by learning what
is php php stands for hypertext
preprocessor a most widely used
scripting language used to design and
develop web applications more on php the
technicalities and the practicalities in
the tutorial ahead followed by php we
will learn mongodb mongodb is a widely
used open source cross-platform database
management system licensed under
server-side public license this database
is one of the most highly interactive
and highly recommended database
worldwide in the id industry now we will
also learn the theoretical explanation
the practical sessions on mongodb as
well now without further ado passing the
control over to our experts
rob is the owner of an e-commerce
business
earlier his customers were very happy
with the products they purchased from
his website
but with more traffic and user base rob
started receiving complaints from his
customers
not related to the products but the
website itself
now the customers were facing challenges
like slow website speed bad user
experience and poor security features
like any other business owner rob wanted
to rectify the problem but he was unable
to find a solution to it
well developing his websites in php can
solve all of rob's problem and guess
what php is simple to learn and easier
to implement
let me elaborate on this
php is useful in many ways as
first and foremost it can make the
website function faster
it can create dynamic web pages and
dynamic web pages are what makes a
website more interactive
next it provides security encryption
it is a cost efficient language
it is very compatible as it works
efficiently with different databases and
programming languages
and it is platform independent which
means a php application can run on any
environment
now before moving into the details did
you know that
79.2 percent web is still powered by php
which nearly translates to 20 million
websites and 1 million web servers
now in this presentation you'll learn
about what is php
how does it work differently from a
conventional web page
what are its features
some major companies where php has
implemented
prerequisites on learning it
and finally
we will have a look at the demo for our
first php program
now without further ado
let's get started
so what exactly is php
php stands for hypertext preprocessor
which is a recursive acronym
it is an open source server-side
scripting language that is embedded into
html and used for web development
now before we get overwhelmed by the
technical terms let me simplify them for
you
now for those of you who don't know open
source is a term for technology which
means it is freely available to everyone
while server-side scripting means that
from writing the code to implementing
and processing it everything is done on
the server side while the user just lays
down and enjoys the experience
now that we know what php is
let's see how php script looks like
as you can see on the screen this is the
syntax of php
it opens with an angle bracket
question mark php and ends with a
question mark and an angle bracket
while the code comes in between them
now as you can so notice
this is very similar to how html codes
are written
now let's have a look at some features
of php
now while php being a very diverse and
feature rich language some of its main
features are listed here
let us try and understand them one by
one
first is simple
now this feature comes as a good news to
new learners since php is simple and
hence an easy to learn language
next comes flexibility
php is a highly flexible language
in conventional webpages even the
smallest of changes have to go through
the developer who changes the code to
implement them well php gives you the
flexibility to make small changes
without the intervention of the
developer itself
it is also platform independent which
means it does not require any special
plugins to run and can basically run on
any environment
next is interpreted php is an
interpreted language and does not
compile the entire code hence taking
less time
which takes us to our next feature that
is
fast
websites developed in php are faster
this is why developing dynamic websites
using php is considered as the best
option
as discussed earlier too php is called
as an open source language which means
it is free to use and implement
next feature is security
the language consists of a few built-in
frameworks that provides benefits like
encryption and hence protection from
cyber attacks
next is a large php community since php
is an old language it has grown up to a
large community which is very helpful
and makes the language more stable so
that was all about features of php
moving forward let us discuss the
workflow of a php web page
how does a ph page work
so for a better understanding let us
first see how a basic html page
functions
in the basic html workflow
when you open a website on your browser
a request is sent from the browser to
the server and the server then returns
the requested page stored on it back to
the browser
now that's it
no matter what device or what purpose
you open the website for the page return
is always the same or you can say static
now what php does different is
when you open a website developed in php
a request in dot php extension is sent
to the server
into the server there exists a php
interpreter which recognizes the dot php
file and interprets it based on the
request from the browser
it pulls out data from its database and
file systems and returns a html page
personalized according to the user
now let me give you an example to make
it more clear
when you log into your account on rob's
new e-commerce website made on php it
takes your unique request to the server
and shows you products based on your
past preference and liking instead of
showing you the exact same page every
time now this makes the website dynamic
and more interactive to the user
also guys before moving forward if you
are enjoying this video please give a
thumbs up and subscribe to simply learn
for more such content
so that was all about the workflow of
php
let us discuss the companies using them
many companies have reached great
success by implementing php into their
websites
let me list down a few of them
first comes facebook the biggest social
media platform
did you know that facebook was created
entirely on php
and according to the website similar web
php is visited by users for nearly 22
billion times per month
this means the social media platform has
to deal with huge traffic volumes and
php helps a website with this
now before moving to the next website a
quick question for you guys
what is the one site everyone goes to
for information
correct it's wikipedia and guess what it
is written in php2
now platforms like wordpress which are
used to create beautiful websites itself
are also based on php
and blogging and social media channels
such as tumblr and even multi-service
platforms like yahoo which face huge
amounts of data traffic every day uses
php to function
so now that i hope you're more motivated
to learn php
let us look at some of the prerequisites
of learning it
now since php scripts as already
discussed are embedded into html codes a
basic understanding of html comes
naturally as a prerequisite
again a website cannot be complete
without the implementation of css hence
a basic understanding of css is also a
must
next is basic knowledge of programming
language now this is not necessarily a
prerequisite but if you have basic
knowledge of programming fundamentals
such as oops concept
functions and errors etc it would really
help you along the way let's get started
and learn what exactly is zam now zam
stands for cross platform
apache server maria database php
and then finally
perl
xampp is an open source application that
is developed by apache friends and is
one of the easiest ways to host a local
web server with access to mysql database
php and perl
so it is an all-in-one package
so now that we have an understanding of
what zamp is let us set up the software
on our system and then see how to use it
to run a php script
so now to set up the xampp software what
we need to do is
let us open the browser
and
download
our software
so as you can see here
apachefriends.org is the official
website from where you can download the
sam software
since we are using the windows version
we'll download it for windows although
it is available for linux and mac os as
well
now let's wait for the download to get
finished
it almost is
now
let's open the setup and install our
software right away
continue installation
next
now from here you can select all the
extra files that you want to install
along with the xampp setup or you don't
want to install
now this is the default folder for xampp
installation that is c drive xampp and i
would recommend you keep it that way
i think there's some issue here
yeah well
this is the
folder for my old xampp
now
we wait for the installation to get
finished and then we'll run a quick php
script a welcome or hello world kind of
script to see how this xampp software
functions along with php
now the installation is almost done
we'll just wait for a few
now the installation is complete and
now
let us open the control panel to check
if it's
done correctly
yes
everything seems fine now so this is the
control panel for the xampp software
which includes all the services provided
by it and in our php tutorials we'll be
mainly using the apache server and the
mysql one
so you need to click on apache server
started and mysql
now apache server will show you the
default port on which it is running now
to check if xampp is correctly installed
on your system let's open the browser
again
and type
localhost
now this will open up the dashboard for
the xampp application
let's click on phpmyadmin
[Music]
and
the information is available here so
the installation is complete
similarly we'll install the visual
studio port since i've already installed
the software on my system i will not be
doing that
now
let us come to the important part
let us redirect to
c drive
and there we have a exam installed
open the xampp folder and locate
htdocs
now this is the folder where all your
php files ports and website related data
will be stored
now we'll open the htdocs and let us
create a new folder here
since it will be a first program let us
name it
first
php
now let's open our code editor that is
visual studio code
click on open folder
locate to
xampp
htdocs
and the folder we created first php
as you can see let me close this first
as you can see first php folder is
visible here
let us create our first php file
let's name it
hello dot php now don't forget the dot
php extension otherwise the code will
not run now since a browser only
understands html code
we will have to embed the php script
into the html code itself so let's begin
let me zoom it a little bit so you can
see clearly
let me
add a heading so h1 will be too big
let's keep it to h2
my
first
php
web page
let's write our first php script so a
php script begins with an opening
angular bracket
question mark
php
now
we'll write the php script that is echo
hello world now echo acts as a print
function which prints any string that is
in front of it in this case it will
display hello world onto the web page
let's close the script with a question
mark and a closing angular bracket
and also close our html code
now before running a web page let us
first check if the web server is still
active
yes the web server is still running
so let's open the browser
type localhost
now type the name of the
folder that you have created that is
first
php
now as you can see our
hello.php file is presented let's click
on it
and as you can see our first web page is
visible
which shows the heading my first php
webpage and the hello world from a php
script in this video on php programming
we are going to discuss different php
concepts from the very basics such as
syntax
hello world program up until learning
how to collect form data using php
scripts and also cover a lot more
concepts in between now what we need to
do is to use visual studio code
what we do is we go to c drive xampp
folder or wherever you have installed
your xampp software we go to that folder
locate htdocs
and let us now create another folder and
you can name it
anything that you want to based on your
project since we are discussing the
concepts let us
name it
concepts
now right click on it and here as you
can see it shows open with code
when you click on it
you can see that it opens visual studio
code for you
along with the concepts folder that we
just created now this is where you will
create all your files for your project
and will be writing all your all of your
php scripts
now let's create the first php file from
here
new file
let us name it tutorial dot php
and
see how a php
syntax looks like
so a php syntax begins with an angular
opening bracket question mark
php
and ends with a question mark and a
closing angular bracket
while
the php script
goes
in between
so this is the very basic syntax of how
php scripts are written
now
let us move on and see
how to write a hello world program using
a php script
so
to print something on php
echo is used
now to use echo what you need to do is
just write the string that you want to
print in front of it
and save the program so
hello
and
welcome
to simply learn
let us close it
and
save the file
now
i am going to show you how to use the
sam software in order to run php scripts
go
and open your xampp control panel
and from the control panel you have to
start this first service that is apache
now this is going to start a local web
server on your system
now open your browser
go to a new tab and type localhost
followed by the name of the folder that
we just created into htdocs that was
concepts
and hit enter
here you can see the file that we just
created tutorial.php
and when you click on it
you can see your first program visible
here hello and welcome to simply learn
now suppose you have a program that
needs to print this exact same string
again and again throughout the program
so
what are you going to do
type the entire echo statement
through your code or make it simpler
now to make it simpler what we need to
do is we need to go back to our code
and discuss the concept of
variables
now to create a variable
what we need to do is we need to
use this dollar sign
followed by the name of the variable you
can name it anything you want so let us
name it str
and type
hello
and
welcome to
simply learn
so
this is a first variable now this
variable str stores this string value
also you can create different variables
for different purposes such as if you
want to store a number suppose
so
you can store number five
and
suppose you want to store a floating
variable
and that would be float and a floating
variable is a number of decimal points
so 7.6
so now we have three variables
in a
program now one thing to notice if
you're coming from a different
programming language is that you don't
need to
define the type of variable in php that
is if it is a string number or a
floating variable
now to print this
we can use echo but when you want to
print a variable in echo you need to do
things a little differently so
let us start with h1 heading
now to print a variable what you need to
do is you need to use
dot
followed by the name of the variable
that would be
str
and another dot
followed by if you want to type
something
along with the variable
i'm going to copy this code
and paste it
now
let us change the size of the headings
and also change a variable so in the
second line we are going to print num
and in the third
the float that we created
so now we have all of our
variables into our echo
now let us save this program and see
what it does
so as you can see
the variables are printed on your
program and you don't have to write them
again and again you can simply write
name of the variable along with echo and
dot and print it along
now that we know about variables suppose
you want to print the names of different
laptop brands available in the market
now what you're going to do
do you create different variables for
each name that is a variable for hbr
variable for lenovo variable for a
source
or do you want a single variable to
store store all of the names of the
laptop brands available
now with errors it is possible to store
different information
of the same data type that is
integer string
under a
single
variable
the condition is all of the
data that is stored under the variable
should have the same data type
now let us see how array works
now
array stores multiple values in a single
variable as we already discussed
now to make an array
first what we need to do is
name a variable
laptop
brand
and
type in
array function
and under that function
we are going to write the names of
different laptop brands that is hp
with separated by commas
lenovo
asus
and
dell
so
suppose these are the four laptop brands
that are available in the market in your
area
now
what you need to do is you need to print
what is
in this
particular variable that is laptop brand
so
to print it
you need to first create
variable dump now what variable dump
does is
it as you can see here
it
exports the variable that is in its
function
now
we are going to
[Music]
write the variable that we just created
into the variable dump function and it
will just return the data type and value
now suppose you want to print it
so to print it what we need to do is
just add echo in front of it
okay now before moving on to seeing the
result of this program
let us just
make this part of the code
inactive
now to do that
we are going to learn a new concept in
between that is comments
so comments are the lines in a code that
are not
executed while
the program is run
so
a single line comment starts with two
slash and anything written in front of
it is does not run along with the code
so
these comments are very useful when
you're writing a
code
to make your code readable and more
understandable by any coder
who will
or might later on using the code that
you just created
now suppose what we can do with
comments is
i'm going to write a comment just in
front of it
this is a
string
variable
now
after
these
slashes
anything written is not executed when
i'm going to run the program
also now
what do you do if you want to make this
whole part of the code not functioning
do you add
two slashes
in front of everything
or you can use a much simpler method
that is multi multi-line comments to use
multi-line comments what you're going to
do is
you slash
star
this marks the start of the multi-line
code and
to end this use star and slash again and
everything in between does not run when
you're going to run your program
so
we will now see
how this
array works
we will just
reload this page and as you can see
hp lenovo asus and dell are visible here
also you might notice
this array 4 shows the length of the
error
and this shows
the position where all of these
strings are inside the array that is an
array starts with the zero position not
one but zero so the first would be zero
position that is hp
and then one lenovo and subsequently
asus and dell
now suppose you just want to print the
second variable in your array what you
need to do is you need to go back to
your code
and
in front of the variable you need to
write the position that you want to
print
under square brackets that is the second
position
in array would be number one
and save the code
go back to the browser
and only the second
array is the second
variable in the array is visible
now suppose instead of a variable you
want to create a value
that you don't want to be changed
throughout your entire program
so
consonants are used for the same purpose
now consonants are very much like
variables except that once they are
defined they cannot be changed or
undefined
so
let us see how consonants work
first
we will
put this code
under a comment
and now start writing a consonant
so to define or create a consonant what
you need to do is
use the
define function
and inside the define function what you
need to do is you need to
write the name of the
consonant
and
okay first let us write the name of the
consonant
suppose
laptops
followed by
the value
of the
hp
consonant
lenovo
and
asus
and that's it and you close the define
function and there you have defined your
consonant in your php script now this
cannot be changed or undefined
throughout your program
now to print it what you need to do is
type echo followed by the name of the
consonant that you just created so the
name of the consonant is laptops
save the code
go back
and hp lenovo and asus
are visible here
can also create consonant errors along
with a normal consonant now to create a
consonant array
you just need to add a square bracket
plus a second
let me close this one
separated by
commas
and now we have
the names of the laptop as an array
which
by the way cannot be changed or
undefined through your throughout your
code just like any other consonant
now suppose you want to just print the
name of the third laptop that is
available in the market
now what you need to do is you need to
write the position and the third
position in case of arrays would be
number two
save
and only asus is visible here
so this is how consonants and variables
work in php
now before moving on to the next section
let me give you another situation
now suppose i want you to print
a number only and only if it is greater
than 7.
how do you do that
now since it is a condition conditional
statements are used to perform different
actions based on different conditions
now some of the conditional statements
include in php
are if
if else
if else if else and switch and we're
going to discuss them one by one
no so the first one is if
now
let me create a variable let us name it
bear
and
write the value 8.
now the example that we just discussed
if we want to check
if
this variable is greater than 7 and only
and only then
print the variable on our screen
now to do that what we need to do is
type in if
and in the bracket we need to type the
condition that we're going to check that
is if
variable
greater than 7
now
use curly brackets
and inside the curly bracket
write the code that you want to execute
only and only if the condition in of
this
if is met
so we need to print this variable
so echo
where
and go and save it now go back
and reload and you can see it is printed
here
now let us go back and change the value
of the variable to 5
and save it
go back reload
and as you can see nothing is printed on
the screen since
the condition that we just mentioned
inside if does not meet
now suppose
i tell you that
if the condition does not meet you have
to
print
a string
saying that the condition does not did
not meet
how do you do that
to do it what you need to add after if
is
else
and else does not need to have a
condition since as
the english
word suggests it is else
which means the condition of if did not
meet and inside the else we're going to
write the code
echo
the
condition
did
not
meet
save it
the condition did not meet
now time for another condition
now suppose i want i ask you to check if
a number is
divisible by 2
3 or both
how do you do that
now to do that
first
let us
create a number
six
now check if
variable
percent
2
is equal to equals to 0 now what this
shows is this
brings out the remainder and if the
remainder is 0 that means it is
divisible by 2.
and we need to add one more condition
here
and
variable
percent three
equals to equals to zero
and
what this does is it checks if both of
these conditions are true that is
if the number
inside the variable is divisible by both
2 and 3
we will display
divisible
by
both
now
what we need to do is we need to
check
if it is divisible by 2
so
else
if
since it is else if we need to add a
condition in it to else if
variable
echo
dev is
built
by
two
similarly
divisible by
three
another you can add as many else if
statements as you want
and the final else will show
okay
let us go back and save our program
since a variable is 6
it should show divisible by both
and you can see it shows exactly the
same divisible by both
now let us change the value
and see if our program works
so what we are going to do is we are
going to change the value to 4.
save a program
and run it again
this by 2
similarly
9
divided by 3
and finally
13
not divided by either 2 or three
so this is how you can make use of if
else if and else statements
now the next conditional statement is
switch statement
now the switch statement is used to
perform different actions based on
different conditions
so let me again give you a situation so
that you understand better
so suppose
you're playing a game
which has four different levels
and
first level is easy medium hard and
extreme
so
you need to print that
now what will you do you can also use if
else if but it's a lot of code
switch statement makes it a lot simpler
and more readable
so
what we need to do is we need to
type in switch
okay first what we need to do is first
we need to create a variable
so a variable suppose
let us name it level
and
level is three
to create a switch statement you need to
type in switch and
enter the name of the variable that will
be passed into the switch statement to
check for the conditions
level
and it also begins with a curly bracket
and inside
the search statement what you need to do
is you need to type case
that is
the first case would be case
one
followed by
a colon
and the statement that you want to
execute that is
echo
you
are
playing at
easy
level
and since you want
your program to stop here itself what
you need to do is you need to type in
break
similarly for rest of the levels i'll
just copy this code here
and just make the changes
okay
and
similar to if else statements you also
need to add another statement that would
be
default
if any of the conditions are not met in
the switch statement suppose the value
of your variable is 20 which does not
make any sense to the game
then
what you need to do is
you need to
display
a default error message and that would
be
invalid
input
and you also need to
end the switch statement
with
a curly braces
and end the
php program
all right
let us save it
go to a browser
and run you are playing at hard level
i guess you must have understood the
concept let us just one more time
change the value of the variable to 20
save it and go back
invalid input
so this is how the conditional
statements in php work
next what we're going to talk about is
php loops
now suppose you want to run a block of
code or a part of code again and again
and again or in other words in loop
so php has that functionality known as
php loops
to do the same task
now there are different types of php
loops available that is while do while
and for loops which we will be
discussing
in this part of the video
now let us start with the while loop now
the while loop
loops through a block of code as long as
the condition that you have entered or
specified in the while loop is true
so
let me just
remove it
now to write a while loop what you need
to do is
type file
followed by
the condition
and to write the condition what we need
to first do is let us create a variable
and
we'll
give it a value of 2.
now the condition
which we are going to write is this is
just an example
so
if
or while
the value of variable
is
less than equals to
10
and then we follow along with the curly
braces
and type the code that we want to run
again and again until the value of a
variable becomes 10
or
till the value of a variable is less
than 10.
suppose
number
and then the variable that is
where
and that's about it
now what we need to do is we need to
increase the value of the variable else
this code this code will run for an
infinite amount of time and the system
might crash so
to increase the variable in each
iteration what we need to do is we need
to use the plus plus operator
which will increase the value of the
variable by one in each iteration
now we're going to save the code
and run it number 2 3 4 5 6 7
and so on
let me just
add
break here and you can see all of the
numbers up until 10
are visible here
and after 10 the loop just stops
so let me
explain it again
so
what we are doing is we are writing
while
along with the condition until
then the code is supposed to be run
again and again
so the condition is if the value of the
variable
is less than or equals to 10 since a
value of
value of our variable is 2 the condition
is true so the code inside of this vial
is executed and the code will display
the value of the number
and the
variable value will increase with each
iteration until it becomes greater than
10 and then
the loop will exit
now the do while loop is very very
similar to the while one
the only difference being
in case of a do while loop
a
code
this this code will execute at least
once
i'll show you how it works
so
in case of do while
we start with two
curly braces
let us use this same
example
and after the curly braces what we do is
we
write
while along with the condition
that is
to 10.
let me just
okay
now let me tell you what do we need low
value suppose
the value of a variable
is
11 now since the condition
does not meet
in case of the while loop it will not
even run once
now suppose you want to display the
current value of the variables whether
or not if it meets a condition at least
once
so in case of do while
it will first go into this do loop
run the code and then after the do loop
is complete this part of the code is
complete it will go on to the vial part
and check the condition
now if the condition does not meet the
loop will end here and if it meets it
will continue until the condition does
not meet the file part
so it will run at least once
now
save this
and go back to a browser
and reload this program and as you can
see number 11
is visible here
so
do while is helpful
in some cases which you'll realize as
long as
you start coding more and more
now next up is for
now for loop is used when
we already know how many times you want
the loop to run
so for loop is used when you want to run
a piece of code a specific number of
times
now let me show you how it works
now the for loop is written in three
parts here we don't need to define a
variable beforehand
the first part of the for loop is
defining the value of the variable so
variable
is equals to let us
value it at one
now we want to make it
run till suppose six values
so what we need to do is
we need to
write the condition
in the second part of the for loop
if variable less than equals to 6
and in the third part will be the
incremental part so as you can notice in
while and do while we put the
incremental part inside the block of the
code here the incremental part is inside
the for
function itself
variable plus plus
and then we start with the curly braces
and we write the
code similar to
i'll just
copy it from here
and now let us
just save it and print to show you
how it works
number one two three four five and six
now these loops are a very important
aspect of programming and you all should
try out different problems based on
loops by yourself
now next up in php is php functions
now functions are very very useful and
very important part of programming in
any language
functions are of two types
built-in functions and user-defined
functions
now built-in functions are the functions
that are already present inside the
framework of your programming language
a very popular example
of a function built-in function of php
is echo echo is a function that is
already built in php and is used to
print out variables strings and values
on the screen
now
user defined functions are functions you
create yourself
to use a code
repeatedly in your program
so i'll explain you with while writing
the code itself
so suppose you want to use this for code
four or five times in your program
so
or even more maybe 10 20 30 40 100 times
in your program if you're writing a very
very large program you want to
print or use this part of the code 100
times in your program what do you do do
you write this entire code or copy paste
this entire code again and again 100
times and make your code
lengthier or do you just want to use
this piece of code
from here
from anywhere in your program
now to do that we need to
put this piece of code inside a user
defined function
so how do we do that
we do that by
writing
function
followed by
suppose you want to call
this function
a name
name
and start with curly braces
now this is a user defined function
named name
now inside this name function
is a piece of code
this
for
now how do we reuse it
i'll show you in a second
so
suppose you are
a long way from your code from this code
you don't even know where it is
you want to use this code again after
writing hundreds of lines of code so how
do you do it you just type the name of
the function
that is name
and close it that's about it this is
called calling a function so
it is similar to calling a friend for
help so here you just called your friend
name
to execute this part of the code
here
save
and where there are no changes since the
output will be the same
let us make some changes
add another echo
i am
going to
run it
again
later
and
call this function again
save it
and as you can see
once the function is called the output
is printed and i'm going to run it again
later and then again the function is
called and it
uses the same piece of code again and
again and again
see how simple coding can be
when you know what to use when
now let's move ahead and understand the
concepts of oops in php
so as you can see on the screen i have
listed down the eight concepts of oops
that we will be discussing today
first is class
next comes objects then it's member
function and member variables then
constructor and destructor
inheritance and finally it is
polymorphism
now let's walk through each of the
concepts one by one
first is class
it is a blueprint of an object that
provides initial values for the state
a class consists of both data and
functions and data and functions
together are called objects
now let's first have a look at the class
let me create a file
named class.php
and let us write the code first
okay
you
here i have defined a class by using the
class keyword followed by fruit which is
the class name
next i have added a pair of curly braces
and added the entire properties and
methods within the braces so as you can
see on the screen we have declared a
class named fruit
that contains two properties called name
and color
along with that i have also added two
methods set name
and get name
now now the purpose of these methods is
for setting and getting the name
property
so let me give you some in important
information so when you define a class a
variable in it is called property while
a function is known as method
now let us execute the code and see the
output
let's go to the browser
and type localhost followed by the file
name
here's a file class.php
and as you can see on the screen
the code is running perfectly
now that was about the class
next comes objects
so it is an instance of a class
basically
a variable holds a date of a class
now we define a class once
and create as many objects in it
so for a better understanding let me
give you an example
suppose a car is a class
so mercedes and bmw would be objects
now let's see objects
classes are incomplete without objects
so we can add as many objects as we want
from a class
and every single object has the
properties and methods defined in the
class
but those objects will have different
property values
so objects of a class are created using
the new keyword
now let me open the code editor
and let's create another file called
obj.php
so this code will be the same
let's copy
and paste it here
now let me type the code for object
[Music]
as you can see i have used the new
keyword to create object of the class
fruit
similarly
banana
would be another object
and now we'll use the set name function
to set
the name to apple on this object on the
apple object that we have created
similarly
we will
set the name
for the banana object
there's an extra bracket here let's move
it
now moving forward let us type the code
to display
what we have added into the objects
for this can you guess which method will
be using
yes the get name method
will be used to display
the name saved onto the object using the
set name method
now that our code is complete
let us run and check
if it's working correctly
let me go back
and refresh
now here we have our object.php file
yes the code runs perfectly the fruit
program
and it is displaying apple and banana
from the two objects that we created
i hope now you have clearly understood
the concept moving on to the next one
let's talk about the member variable and
member function
a member variable is defined within a
class
the data can be accessed by the member
functions alone now once the object is
built these variables are called
attributes of the object
whereas member function is defined
within a class and is used to access
object data so next comes constructor
so it allows an individual to alert an
object's properties
while the object creation
while a destructor is a function that is
called when the object stops working
we will have a look at the constructor
program
so constructor allows an individual to
alert an object's properties while the
object creation
now suppose you build a program using
constructor function
php will automatically call the
construct function while creating an
object from a class also remember that
when you write the construct function
always prefix it with two underscores
now let's have a look at the example
where we will be using a constructor
function with calling the set name
method
now this set name function is often used
when you assign a value to the name
attribute
now let's open the code editor and
create a constructor file
[Music]
we'll again create the two properties
named
name
and color
now we will create a constructor with
two underscores
and a construct keyword
and i'll give the two properties as
attributes to the constructor
now in this
program we'll be using the constructor
function
as the set
method
to set the names
and color of a fruit by default
during the object creation itself
we still need to create the get
functions
this
now let's create an object to invoke the
constructor
now since the constructor has attributes
we will have to give the values for the
attributes as well
so the fruit would be
strawberry
and color
would be pink
so this creates a new object and it
gives
the values to the constructor
um
in the php script
and
our html code as well
let us save the code and check if it's
working
let's go back
refresh
now constructor file is visible let's
click on it and yes
so
when the object strawberry is created
the attributes we have given to the
constructor strawberry and the color
pink were already
assigned to it
and it is displayed in the browser
itself
now that the constructor program is done
next let's see an example of how a
destructor works
let's open the code editor
create another file
destructor.php
now the destructor code will be very
similar to the constructor one so we
will copy the code
into the destructor file and make some
changes
so
let us remove this we don't need it
and write our destructor function
so destructive function is written
similarly
how constructor function is written so
it starts with two underscores and a
destruct keyword
it does not have an attribute
now why did we delete the get functions
is because
we will be using the destructor
for it
also we won't be needing this
just the object creation is sufficient
now let's save our program and
do the drill again
open the browser
here a destructor file is visible
and it shows the fruit strawberry and
the color is pink so when the object
function is complete
and the program ends the destructor
function is called which displays the
strawberry and the color pink
now comes inheritance so it derives new
classes or child classes from the parent
class
however inheritance can have its own
properties and methods too
so inheritance has two classes
first is parent class and the other one
is a child class
now let's talk about each of them in
detail
so parent class is otherwise called a
base class that is inherited from
another class
and a child class is a subclass that
inherits from another class
a child class can have subclasses and
derived classes
now let's have a look at the inheritance
program
so the child class is derived from all
the properties and methods from the
subclass
in addition it can have its own
properties and methods too
so an inherited class is defined by
using the extends keyword
let's look at an example
let's open the code editor so i've taken
the liberty to create the
inheritance.php file
and write some of the code that we have
already written so i'll be writing only
the code that is necessary for the
inheritance part
now also remember when you derive a
child class from a parent class only the
public methods are derived into the
child class
so we will be creating the methods as
public
in order them to be
inherited
made this function public
let's
end this class
and create another class in order
to inherit this class
so we'll name
another class as
cherry
extends
fruit
and we'll create another function for
cherry
so this function is exclusive to cherry
so we have given a message through this
method
now
let's create an object
cherry
new
cherry
and
give the values for the attributes
of
this constructor
let's save the code
and check if it's working
well there seems to be an error
now let's try to resolve it
okay got it so we
created the object
within
the cherry class so it got localized
what we need to do is put that code
outside of the cherry class
and it should work fine now
yes so is cherry a fruit or a berry a
cherry is a fruit and the color of the
fruit is red
and now we will talk about the last
concept that is polymorphism so
polymorphism has many forms
the same function is utilized for
different purposes
it has a class with a variety of
functions simultaneously sharing a
common interface
so inherited methods are overridden by
redefining the methods in the derived
class now let me write the code to make
it clear
so already created the polymorphism php
file
i have copied the inheritance code
into the polymorphism part
and then now we will make the changes
into the derived class that is cherry
so let's create a property named
weight
now to
override the constructor and the intro
function
from the fruit class we will have to
create the same functions
in the derived class also
this function construct has got one
extra attribute in comparison to this
function construct
so
let's create the intro function too
i
now a code is ready let us create
another object
to invoke
the functions
now did you notice what we did here
so
when we created the object cherry for
for the cherry class we gave three
attribute values instead of two
in order to invoke this construct
function
not this
let us run it and check
so it runs perfectly it displays the
fruit the color and the weight
in this video we will discuss some php
extensions that can be and should be
added in visual studio code to make php
programming a little easier and a life's
a little simpler
now to check the extensions available or
search any of them we need to go to this
tab that is the extensions tab
now these are the already installed
extensions on our system
and from here you can search
extensions available in the visual
studio called marketplace
now the first extension and a must-have
extension is
php
intellifence
now to understand what it does let me go
back to
the explorer
and open a test.php
so what i'm going to do is
write some
basic php built-in functions
let us say
php
info so
what you need to notice is when you type
php info
it shows a suggestion it is from the
built-in feature that is already
installed into the visual studio code
but when you click on this
that's it
now i'll show you the difference
go back to extensions
and install php intellifence
now go back to
your test file
and again
type php
info now as you can notice you can see
two php infos here now when you click on
this one
you can see all the details about this
function
available
right here so this is what
php intel fence is it intelligently
suggests an auto autofills parts of your
code to make your programming simpler
and much easier
now moving on to a second extension our
second extension will be
php
mess detector
now what phpmes detector does is it
analyzes your php code on every save
now there's no additional setup required
if php is already installed on your
system which already is
so
to see what it does
let us install it
now before that let us go back to test
test.php
and let me just
open this
now here you can see the output of your
code so if you go back to phpmes
detector install it
and go back to your code
you can see phpmes detector is visible
here and after
everything
that you write
it analyzes your code after every save
and it is pretty useful while writing
big and complex php codes
now let's move on to the next extension
which would be
php
auto
close tag
now what php auto close tag as the name
suggests does is when you open a tag
when you whenever you write a tag that
is suppose html
or body etc etc anything that you write
it will automatically close the tag and
you can simply start writing the code
so
this extension has saved me a lot of
time finding what problem is in my code
fixing the bug
when actually it was just that i did not
close the tag
so
suppose
i write html
and as you can see it automatically
closes the tag and you can simply start
writing the code
now moving on to a next step that would
be
php fmt that is php formatter
now
what it does is it formats your code
with proper indentation and
well your code looks much more readable
after this
so
let me just show you
i've already created a test2.php
let me just close this so as you can see
this code is not indented at all
and one might have trouble understanding
what is going on and what part of code
is under what
loops and
statements so
we go back to our extension php
formatter
install it
go back to test one
sorry test2
now
when you right click
after installing this extension you can
see format document section available
then when you click on it
the code gets automatically
indented and looks much more readable
now so
as you may notice
all these codes under comes under the if
conditions
and
the rest of the code looks much more
readable now
now the last extension that i am going
to discuss is
php
debug
now this extension
you may not use it on a very regular
basis but this extension is very helpful
when you want to debug your code and see
what's wrong with it
all the instructions on how to use this
extension are written alongside it and
how to install how to use how to
install extra servers in order to
completely utilize its potential
since this extension is a debug adapter
between visual studio code and xdebug
website that was developed by derrick
ruthens
so
i am going to install it
and this is the very website x debug
where
any of your code is debugged
so these are some of the extensions that
you need to begin or ease your journey
into php
there are a lot more extensions
available for php
and you can explore more into them as
you move forward
we will look at php in get and post
so all of us know that php is a
scripting language for creating web
pages but what is get in post
there are two ways the browser client
can send information to the web server
the get method and the post method
let's understand get method in detail
first
the get method sends the encoded user
information appended to the page request
the page and the encoded information are
separated by the question mark character
now let's know more about the get method
the get method produces a long string
that appears in your server logs in the
browser's location box
it is restricted to send up to 1024
characters only
also
never use the get method if you have a
password or other sensitive information
to be sent to the server since it will
show in the browser's location box
next the get can't be used to send
binary data like images or word
documents to the server
also the data sent by get method can be
accessed using the query string
environment variable
now let us try writing a code to
understand the get method better
so as you can see we have got the output
but if you look at the link
it has an ampersand symbol along with
the username and age we entered
now before the browser sends the
information it encodes it using a scheme
called url encoding
in this scheme name value pairs are
joined with equal sign and different
pairs are separated by the ampersand
also as we discussed earlier the page
request
and the encoded information is separated
by a question mark sign
so that was all about the get method
moving on to the next one let's have a
look at the post method
now the post method transfers
information via http headers
the information is encoded and described
in the get method and put into a header
called query string
the post method does not have any
restrictions on data size to be sent
the post method can be used to send
ascii as well as binary data and the
data sent by post method goes through
http header so security depends on http
protocol used by using secure http you
can make sure that your information is
secure
now let's have a look at the code now
now you must be wondering if both the
methods give the same output so what is
the difference between them
well the major difference between post
and get method is that get method
carries request
parameters appended in url string as you
can see here the parameters are visible
in the url
while post carries request parameters in
message body which makes it more secure
way of transferring data from client to
the destination as you can see there is
no information in the url
now a lot of people have raised a
request to create a code on the request
method too so let me tell you the
request variable can be used to get the
result from form data sent with both the
get and post methods
let us try out a code for the request
method two
as you can see we have got the output
today we will learn how to link mysql
database to your html code with the help
of php
now to do that we will build a simple
registration form whose data will be
uploaded to the mysql database
and in this tutorial you will learn how
to create that database how to link it
to your web page and also how to delete
the tables or entries from the database
now before proceeding i am expecting
that you guys have some basic
understanding of html php and mysql
so
without further ado
let's get started
also guys for this tutorial we'll be
working on zam and visual studio code
now let's get started
so first we'll open the c drive zam
folder htdocs and let us create a
folder let's name it
tutorial
and open the visual studio code and
start writing the code for a
registration page
let's create a file
and name it index.php
okay
let's give the title as registration
form
and close the head
now let's give
some heading to a registration page
now to make it a little more interesting
let us suppose the registration page is
for a blood donation camp
so
we will
name our heading as the blood donation
camp
and close it
now let's give some
background color
to the page
now to give some background color we
need to first know the code for it
let's search for color codes
well i like the saffron one
let's copy the code
paste it here
[Music]
a heading for the
page registration form
now as you can notice i
wrote this heading as h1 and this one
has h2 since this will be a little
smaller from the first one
let's close the div
and write a form
now
in this action part
write connect dot php and this is the
file which will be creating later in
order to connect our registration page
to the database
and method
as
post
let's name it user
so the first
entry would be
name
input type
would be
text
and we have to give
every entry a name
in order to use it in the php code to
connect to a database
let's give this name
name
now what i did here is i put the
required keyword here which would make
it compulsory in to
fill this
section of the form
in order to continue
i'm giving these break lines to
not make the form
clumsy
email
so
naturally this would be the label for
email
and let me skip ahead with this section
so i have written the code
for the different fields that we are
going to have in a registration page
so the first one was name second email
third would be the phone number and
fourth obviously the blood group
of the person registering
as you can notice i have given necessary
type for different fields so for email
i've given the type as email
for blood group text and phone as text
in case someone wants to enter the
entire phone number with the country
code
so now let us create an input button
that would be submit
and name
let us keep it submit
id would be
submit
let's close our form
and close the
web page too
now let's save it and check
if it's working correctly
now let's open the browser
before that
first we need to open the sam control
panel and
start our apache server and mysql server
and now let us go to the localhost
type a folder name that is tutorial
and open the form
well there seems to be a problem the
other fields are not visible
let's open a code and see
what did we do wrong
yeah well there's a spelling mistake
here
and since i copy pasted the code
the mistake got copy pasted too
well
let's save it again and check if it's
working correctly
yes perfect
now before moving on to creating our
connect.php file we first need to create
our database itself
so first we need to go to exam control
panel and click on admin
now this will open the php my admin
section
where
we will go to new
and create a
database okay let us name our database
as
test1
let us give it five fields and name it
you source
first field would be id
and it would be auto implemented
second we will name it as name
250
email
this will also be backer
third one would be
phone
variable characters since people can
enter the plus sign
to enter the
country goods
and finally we will have our blood group
and let's create our
table here
well as you can see this is a structure
of the table and the table is created
now when you click on browse
it will show you the data in this table
itself
since we haven't entered any data yet it
is blank
now let's
open up
code editor and create a file
connect
dot php
and
let's get started
now here we will have to enter
the name we gave to us submit button
and that would be submit
now we will create a variable to
create a connection and we'll be using
the mysqli
underscore
connect function to do that
[Music]
here we will have to enter the name of
the server since we our server is the
locally hosted server so we will have to
type localhost
now the
type of user that would be root
now the third part is for the password
since we don't have a password for our
database it would be blank
and the fourth would be the name of our
database that is test one
now we will also check
if connection
is not complete
we will have to display an error
connection field
now in this if condition we will check
if the entries in the fields
of the registration form
are null or not
we will have to do the same for the
second
second one was
sorry i did not enter the
yeah
email
a third entry
was
phone
and our fourth and final entry would be
the blood group
i think we're done here
[Music]
now we will have to create
variables
to pick data from the
registration fields in a registration
page
now this post
will be picking data
what we'll be entering here
now here we will have to enter
the name
we have given
here
so for the name field we have given the
name as name itself so we'll be writing
it here
let's
copy this code
and make the changes
this would be
email
let us also name it email
this would be
phone
this would also be born and
last one would be
blood group
because i am naming the these variables
same as the name i've given because
naming everything differently would just
create confusion in your code
now let us enter these details into our
database now insert into sql command
now this
would be
the table name
users
name
email
phone
and
blood group
now we will have to
send the respective values
that would be the
variables that we just created
so first would be
name
second would be email
phone
and
black
now that we have entered the
data into the database let's create a
query
connect it
to the command
and give a message if it's successful or
not
and to successful
else
error
occurred
let us close our php script here
and save the code
and let's see if it's working
so
let's go back to a registration form and
give some
details to it
so
let us name
sam
sam at the rate
mail.com
would be one two three four five six
seven eight and the blood group
can be o positive
well there's some error that we've
experienced
on line four
okay
let's see
yeah we did not close this
okay let's save it
and try again
another on line 12
what do we have here now
okay so this is my sql i not mysql
save
resend the form and entry successful now
the entry is successful you need to go
to your database which i've shown to you
earlier
go to the table users
and
we can see the details present here sam
sam at the rate mail.com the phone
number and the blood group
so now that we know how to create a
database
link our database to a html form
and see the details into the database
entered
we can also delete these details
from this phpmyadmin section itself
so as you can see
to delete this field i just have to
click on this delete button
okay and the field is gone
also if you want to delete this users
go to your database
click on users and click on drop
what it will do is it will drop the
entire table
and if you want to delete your database
itself click on this database
icon
and click on drop the database
now this will remove the entire database
and all the tables associated with it
now let's enter
one more detail set of details to double
check it
let us give it mac
that would be
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
and the blood group would be a
positive and the entry is successful
so to check it we need to go to a
database our table users
and there we have it math mac address
mail.com and the
rest to the details
today we are going to have a video
session on php form validation
so what does this actually mean
okay well let me give you an example
here so when you try to create an
account on facebook or instagram you
submit a form and then that form is
cross verified with the code written in
the backend
so today we are going to do the same
process in this video
now we will have a look at two demos now
in the first demo we will create a form
and in the second one we will validate
it
so let's get started with the first demo
but first things first
let's quickly open
c drive xampp folder htdocs and
create a folder
let's name it validation
and open our code editor here
and let's create a first file
form dot php
now i am going to write the code for the
registration form
so
now here what we're doing is we are
creating the different variables for the
form
and we are setting it to empty values
let me put that in a comment too
okay
thank you
now as you can see the
form will contain full name email number
comment gender and age
now for this demo the username
email and mobile number fields will be
text input elements while the comment
field will be a text area
let's write the next rest of the
now we are defining the
test input function which we are calling
in the above if statement
let's start creating the form
and add the method to
post
action would be
what's up
okay
so i skipped ahead and created all the
details required in the form so the
details would be full name
its input type would be text
uh just
yet
okay now
second would be email similarly number
h comment now notice the comment would
be a text area instead of a simple input
type
gender
and a submit button
now the form is complete
we have to write another php script to
display the details
okay
[Music]
i'll just skip ahead in this part too so
now that we can display all of the
variables from the form let's close
the php script
and also
close our
form
now let me explain some parts of the
code to you before we move on to
the web page part
so
here we have
post
so this function is used at the time of
form submission now during that time the
form data is sent with
method
equals to post
second would be the server section
now this server php self is a global
variable that returns the file name of
the code
now also html special characters
function converts special characters to
html entities now this prevents
attackers from exploiting the code by
injecting html or javascript codes
that is cross site referencing scripting
attacks in forms
so now that we know what these functions
do
let us jump and see if a webpage works
okay
for that first open sam control panel
and start the apache server
and now let's open the browser
and type localhost followed by the
folder name that would be
validation
and then a file name form.php
so yes the form looks good let's
add some name to it
email
xyz.com
number is optional but let's add some
number to it
it would be 20
comment would be
hello
welcome to
simply learn
gender would be male and let's click
here
yes so our input is visible and the form
works perfectly
now let's move on ahead with our second
demo that is validating a form
now we will be writing a code but with
slight variations now the fields like
full name email address and websites
will be added here and these three
fields will show an error if an
incorrect input is given now however the
code is validated against the input and
returns an alert message if an incorrect
data is entered
let's go to the code editor
and create another file
and let's name it
validate.php
and write
another code for it
so
[Music]
now added some
color for the
error that will be shown into the
form
again
let us write comment for it define
variables
and
set to
empty
and our variables would be named err
that is error
similarly email
here
gender
err
and the rest of fields
yes
foreign
now let's give the else command for it
now if
no error found or the field entered is
correct
the name will be displayed as we
displayed the name in the form.php file
with the help of post
name
now what we are going to do is now we
will check if name only contains letters
and white spaces
so
you
and this would be
er
you
now we will check
if the email address is well formed or
not
to do that we will again use an if
statement
i think i have used
emi somewhere
since it's showing here emai
so let's check before it throws an error
in a code
there's email yeah
okay we made a mistake here so this else
was not supposed to be closed here
let's move it ahead
yeah i think
this looks good
let's
write
another code for
another variable
that is
website
and do the same thing again
website
now we will check if the url address
syntax is valid or not so
let's just be assembling
you
now we will write the
test input function as we did
in the form section so let's just
copy it from there since it's going to
be the same
now let's write
the php script
for the form
validation section
home method would be post
action would be
php script again
i'll just skip ahead with this part of
the program
so now that we have a complete form here
let's
close it
as you can see we have entered full name
email address website comments and
gender parts to the
form
now let's write our final php script to
display the details
since this will also be similar to the
last part
we will just copy it from the
and make the necessary changes
so
what we don't have is
full name this would be just name email
now this would be
a website
there's no number
it's
it
there's a comment and there's a gender
let's close the script
and also close our
webpage
now let's save the file
open a browser and check if our web page
is working correctly
type localhost
name of the folder
and the name of your file
okay
so let's write something mac
mac x y z added now let's not write
something after it so that the email
address would be wrong
just to check
one two three
dot
see
comment
anything would do
gender mail and let's click on submit
so as you can see
it shows enter a valid website url and
the email address is incorrect
let us also check by writing
an incorrect name that would be mac1
email address
mac x y z at the rate and one two three
dot c
now it's showing the error for the name
two
okay let's write something that is
correct
mac
gmail.com
website would be www.simplylearn.com
comment could be anything
mail
and no errors here
as you can see we have got the output
today we are discussing everything about
tread operators in php
let's begin with the definition first
trud stands for create
read
update and delete
these are the four fundamental functions
of persistent storage
these operators are used in creating
user interface conventions that help us
to view
search and modify data via computer
based forms and reports
basically the data is read built updated
and deleted
moving forward let me talk about the
purpose of these operations one by one
with the help of demo codes
but first things first let's create a
database
to do that
open xampp control panel and start
apache and mysql
now let's quickly open our web browser
open the localhost and go to phpmyadmin
section
now let's
create a new database and
name it
my bb
let's name the table users and we will
have
six fields in it
the first would be id it would be
integer and auto incremented since it
would be the primary key
the second
would be
first
name type back here
let's give it 250
the third would be
last name
variable character
similarly
next would be an email
password
and finally
gender
so now that our table has been created
let's move on to the coding part
now first we are going to create a
file named config.php
to configure
the database
now we will create
variables
and i will explain the use to you
later
this is the
default username for a localhost
now the default password for a database
is empty since there is no password in
our database
and the database name
would be my
db
that's what we have named a database
now let's quickly create the connection
using
pawn variable
my sqli command
server name
username
password
and the database name
now this will create a connection
for our database
and now
let's
also
check
for errors while creating the database
now if an error is found while
connecting to the database
it will show a message as connection
field
now let's end the file
and move on to understanding the
different thread operations
now first comes create
so let us also create a new file and
name it
create dot php
now the create procedure adds the insert
statement to create a new record now
let's write the code
for this
now what this line will do is it will
act as a link between the configuration
dot php file
and this create.php
to connect to the database
now
we are checking
if the submit button
on the form is pressed
now when the submit button on the form
will be pressed
the
fields
are required to be sent to the database
for that we first need to create
different variables
similarly
last name
these are the names that we have given
to the
different sections in the table of our
database
password was password
and finally
gender
now let's write the sql query
insert into the name of the table that
is users
and now
we need to name the
fields we are going to be entering the
details into
since id is auto implemented we are
going to be starting with first name
similarly last name
email
password
and
lastly
gender
now
these are the fields we are going to be
entering data into
now the values
would be
the variables that we just created which
are
getting the data from the form using the
post function
into the variables
so
first name
similarly
last name
email
password
and gender
so
the code
to enter the
values into the database is complete
now let's also execute the query
[Music]
to do that
we will send the query using the connect
and
put the attribute as sql
fields
now
if the records are created
it will display a successful message
else
in case of an error
it will
show a error message
now let's
close the connection
close function
and move on
to creating a html form
[Music]
now let's give
a heading here
now this since this is a registration
page let's give the headings sign signup
form
[Music]
you can create
the form
let's leave the action field as blank
and method
would be since we're using post
the method would be
post
[Music]
so
[Music]
now i'll just skip ahead with this form
part now as you can see i've completed
the code for the registration form which
will include the first name
last name password
and gender
now let's
save it
and move on to the next part
that is the view procedure
now the view procedure table records
data based on the primary key noted
within the input parameter
now let's create
another file
named
view.php for it and write its code
now i will run
the entire code in a single go and
explain
how these different card operations are
working on the web page
now let's write the query
to get the data from the users table
from
users
now this will
retrieve all the data into from the
table
also let us execute the query
using
connect
query and pass
sql into it
and the php script
and right are
html
code
title would be
view
page
now i'm linking this page to a bootstrap
css document
to make it look
somewhat stylish
since basic html page looks pretty
boring
or to do that we are going to be
using the reference
and i have added the link for the css
file
now let's
complete the
rest of the page
heading to this division
users
now this will also display the id from a
table
so we are going to be creating a
different set of
column
to display the id
similarly
it will be the same for the
rest of the fields so i'll just
copy this code
this will be for email
gender
and editor
[Music]
gender
and action
let's close it
let's put it
next time
so this will check
there is data present in
our database
now if there is data
we are going to be
fetching the
same data
um
similar codes will be written for the
rest of the fields
so we will just
let me
just copy and paste
and change
the details
first
name last name
email
and
gender
uh
you
these are the codes for the edit and
delete commands
and
finally let us
close the page
now let's quickly move on to the
third part
update
file and write its
code
now
when the update button for the form is
clicked
we need
this code to process it
and similarly
for the rest of the fields
let's quickly change
user id
this would be id
last name
last name
all of our
variables are complete now let's write
the query
for the sql
update
name of the
table
users
and set
name
is equals to
first name
and similarly
for the rest of the code
now
let's execute the query
pass sql to it
again if
the record is a
successful updation
pass successful message
and
if any error is occurred
we will give an error message for it
now if
id variable set in the url we need
we know that we need to edit a record to
do that
we will
again write a code
using get method
now we will write sql command
to get the data
and
execute a query
uh
okay
this is a very similar code to what we
have written earlier
to fetch the data if the number of rows
is greater than zero
now what i am going to do is i am going
to
also skip ahead for the code
for this
update form
now this is the code for the update form
and now
last but not the least
we will
create the file
for delete
and write a code
very similar to how we have written the
rest of the codes
let's write the sql query the same old
routine
so
as you guess i'm going to be skipping
ahead with some of the parts some part
of the code
now this is the code for our delete.php
file
and now
we will save all these files
and
go to a browser and try to run
check if they run correct now let's
open the localhost first and go to
phpmyadmin
and open our
choosers field here
so as you can see i've already created a
record here i'll
create another one to show you how
for that let's go to localhost
demo
and
go to create.php
so second record let's name it mac
x
simply learn
b
now the email would be map x at the rate
password
and
submit new record created successfully
now let's refresh it and as you can
notice we have created another record
here
now
let's go
to localhost again
and
what was our next operation for crud it
was c create
our
read that would be view.php now view.php
displays both of the records that we
have saved
in our database
now
these number differences would be
because i have created and deleted two
more records before recording this part
of the video
now let's go
to
edit section of any of this record
so
as you may notice it opens the
update.php file
user update form
also the thing to notice is that it
refers to the id that we are updating in
the url itself
now since we clicked on the edit part
of the first field
it is updating the first field itself
now let's update this
miss
xxx
jbc
xyz.com
and update
record updated successfully now let's
check the record
and yes the record is updated
now
since we are done with the two parts
create read
and even the third part update cru now
let's move on to the d that is delete
let's go to the delete
for that we would have to
go to the
view.php itself
now
let us delete this
second field mac simply learn b mac x
addressing lnb.com
delete
now
you may notice the url delete dot php id
4 now id equals 4 is deleted from the
database
let's check
and yes the file from the database has
been deleted
so
this is how we perform our credit
operations with the help of php and
mysql database
in this video we will learn how to
create a registration page using php
html some css and xampp software
then
we will use that data
and store it in a mysql database
so
let us begin and start writing a code
first now to do that
we need to go to my computer c drive
now zam folder this is the folder where
the xampp software is installed
here
locate to htdocs
and let us now create a folder for our
tutorial and
name it tutorial
now we'll open this folder in visual
studio code
and start writing a program
so let us create a first file here
and name it
register
dot
html now this will be the html file that
is the whole structure of how a
registration page will look
so
now
[Music]
registration
page now this will be the title
of a web page
i think that's enough
now let us move on to the
body of the page
now i'm going to write
register
in an h1 point
for the heading
and
now we'll create a form
action would be
the name
register.php
and method
or tree
post
okay so
the first label that i'm going to create
will be for the username
so in a registration form i'm going to
keep it simple i'm just going to include
three categories that would be username
password and a third one would be email
so
to create the label for
username
so you always have to keep in mind
whatever name you're giving here or in
the database whichever you write first
since the name has to match
so i'm giving username the name username
and that's it for a label
now let us create another label
for
before that
input type for this
will be
text
name as we've already written
will be username
placeholder with display
username
and i am going to put this field as
required
which means that the
user cannot leave this field empty
second one would be
label for
password
now i am going to give its input type
as
password
and you will know the reason later
you can also give input type for the
password as text but it will not be
secure then
password
id will be
password
and this is also a required field
now let us move on to
the label
for our last section that will be email
and
give its
input type
email yes and email can be set as an
input type
name
email
placeholder will display
email
and you guessed it right this is also
a required field
i think
this is it for the registration html
now we move on to
creating our
css page in order for this html
structure to look good
well wait a second i left off of a
pretty important section of the
registration form that is the register
button itself
so
let me just
not form
let me just create
the
registration
for
registration button
and will be of type submit
and value
displayed would be
registered
now we'll move on to creating the css
file
and
let us create a new file and name it
style.css
so the code for style.css is already
prepared so instead of writing the
entire code line by line i'm just going
to paste it
and
you can see how it works
so this is the css code that will make
a registration form
look a little better
so i have created different sections
for different sections of the
registration form so this will be the
registration from input button
this is for the color of the
submit button
and
the rest of the form as you can see
now in order for the style.css file to
work we need to link this file
style.css to register.html
now how do we do that we go on to the
register.html
back
and we add
just
one extra line in the head of the
program
so
here what we are doing is
we are referencing our style.css page
into this page itself
and that's it
now both of these pages that we've just
created are linked to each other and now
at least a registration form
structure is complete
it does not work yet but it will soon
now before creating the register.php
code
let us first create a database
so that we have some understanding of
what is going on around everything so to
create a database what we need to do is
open xaml
start the apache and mysql server
now go to your browser
and open the localhost
phpmyadmin
now create a new database
let us name it
form
click on create
now let us name our table as users
number of columns would be
four
the first column will be id
which will be auto incremented
second will be username
make sure to use the same name that
we've used in the code so that
the code does not malfunction
it will be of type
variable character
password
will also be a variable character
email
and now
so as you can see this is the structure
of our
table
of database form
now let us move on to finally writing
the rest of the code for our
registration form
so now that we have a database complete
let us move on to a back to our code and
create a register.php file
now the first thing that we need to do
while creating the php code is
we need to connect our code with our
database that we just created so this is
why i stopped in between and created a
database so that you need
you understand better how this code is
functioning
now database host
since
we are using xampp to locally host a
server
this will be
localhost
a user will be the root user
since we have not set any password on
the database it will be empty
and finally
the name of our database
what did we name a database
it was form
now i will create
a variable con
to
connect
to connect a database
with our code
so we have created host
user
password
and finally
name
now
we have got to add an error message
which will check
if
the database is
connected or not
so
will be
[Music]
error
connecting to the
database
now let us add some code
to check if any variable is
empty or not
okay
now if any of the field is left empty
while filling the registration form it
will display the following message empty
field
now
let us add another
code and check
bye
so now that we have added validation
into a code
now what we need to do next is
check
whether the username or the details that
have entered that the user has entered
the registration form already exists or
not
and if it does
display an error message and if
the details are new enter the details
into a database
now to do that
let us write another if statement
now here i am writing
an sql command which will
select
id
password from users that is the name of
a table
where username and
here we are going to check if the
username entered still exists or not
look
now if the number of rows is greater
than zero which means username already
exists so we need to display
an error message that would be username
already
exists
try
again
and if it does not
now in this else part we will be writing
the code for to send our data into the
database
now here
instead of selecting we are going to
insert the data into
users which is a table
and
the fields will be username
password
email
and that's it
now the password variable
is going to fetch
the details
of the password here
and email
add another statement
to
execute
and display
another message now since we have
entered our data into the database we
need to display
a following message too
this would do
now
this will display
an error message in case something goes
wrong
and now
since we have completed this part of the
code
let us end a statement
close the connection with the database
here and end our php script
so now that our code is complete now let
us run
the code and check if it works fine
so
our apache server is running
let's go back to a browser
open the localhost name of the folder
so as you can see register pages are
visible here
register.html
and create
a user
tony
at the rate and
you have successfully registered and you
can now login
so
let us now check
if it's visible in our database
so our database is forms
users
and as you can see the
file that we just created tony
is visible here in a database
along with the email and
one thing that you may notice is that
the password is not visible here since
we use the hash protection for passwords
so passwords will not even be visible to
the
database admins
so this is how you create a registration
form with the help of html php exam and
mysql database
in this tutorial we'll create a simple
login system using php and mysql now
this tutorial is comprised of two parts
in the first part we'll create a login
form and in the second part we'll create
a local also we will show you how to
create a database in order to access the
login web page as well now first things
first let us quickly go to c
zam htdocs and create a folder let's
name it demo and quickly open our visual
studio code now for this tutorial we'll
be creating a set of files for different
functions now there will be six in total
let us first create these files and
we'll write the code later now the first
file would be index.php
now this is the file that will be
responsible for the login page where
we'll enter a username and password to
login now the second file would be
login dot php now this file will be
responsible for how our login system
will work similarly
there will be a logout file that will be
responsible for how our logout function
will work next
would be
home.php now this is the file for our
home page when we login into our account
next would be a file to link our web
page to the database that would be
database connection dot php and finally
we'll add a css file to make the page
look better now let's get on to writing
a code first let's begin with index.php
now in this page we will create
the login page
let's
add the title
as login
now here i am going to link this page to
the css file that we are going to write
later
now in this reference
we will refer it to the style.css file
we created
let's create a form
now since
login.php is responsible for how our
login page will work we will link this
index.php to login.php
method would be
first
let us add a heading
login
now this part of the code will be
checking for error and displaying error
if
something wrong happens
now we will
add our
username and password fields
let's add another label for password
input type would also be password
now let us
add the
login button
it would
say login
and our form here
now our index.php
code is complete now let's move on to
login.php
and
write its code
now what we are going to do is we are
going to connect this page with the
database page
now here
we will be validating the data entered
in the form
let us
create a variable
for username and password
make sure not making any spelling
mistakes otherwise
you will run into errors
[Music]
now
what this code is doing
is it's checking if there's an entry in
the username and password field and if
it is empty it will display the message
as username is required
similarly what we're going to do is
we are going to create an elsif
that would check if the password field
is empty
and display an error message
in a similar way
now that is set up let's import our data
from our database now we have not
created the database yet but
we'll write the sql query and we'll
create a database later now what i'm
going to do is i'm going to name my
table as users so here i'm writing
select star from users where
username
would be
the
value we passed and similarly
password
would also be the value that we
passed
now this is where if the password and
username match with what we have in a
database it will display a message as
logged in
now we are going to create a session
that would be a login session
now id will also be a field in a
database that would be auto incremented
and work as the primary key
okay if function is complete
time to write the else part
now the else part would be if the
username or password you have entered
does not match with the one we have in a
database so it would display incorrect
username or password as the error
message
location will be same index.php
so now
we have our login.php file also complete
now let's get on to our home.php file
and quickly
write the code for it
we will start the session
now this
would be our home page
let us also
link it to the
css file
tile dot
css
now
with this php script we will display
the username of the person that's logged
in so suppose my username would be mac
so it would display hello mac we will
very soon see the practical demo for it
too
now we will link this home page with the
logout session that is
logout.php
and
end this
okay so home.php is also complete so
next would be to work on the lower part
now this is a very small code since it
is only working to in any session that
has been created
now first unset the
session
and
then
destroy it
now can you guess the location
it would be
index.php now see this is all the code
for the logout file now finally we will
move on to database connection file
where we will connect our entire web
page these entire four files to the
database
so
we are going to create variables for
let us name it since we have already
used unnamed for username now this is
the name for the server and since we are
hosting a server locally it is localhost
now the next variable would be for the
name of the
okay let us let us change the spelling
this would be name of the default
database
password would be blank since by default
there is no password and
this is the name of the database that we
are going to keep now
let us keep the name of our database as
test underscore database
now we will pass
the variables
that we just created
now
we will check if the connection that we
have created is
working or not and if not we will
display a message as connection failed
now all of our files are complete the
only thing left is style.css
now since style.css is only for the
looks of the of the webpage and is not a
very necessary file for our login
function i will just copy paste the code
that i have already written and let us
now move on to creating a database now
to do that first open xampp control
panel
and go to your browser
and type
okay
localhost go to phpmyadmin
and click on new database now
the name that we wrote for the database
in our code was test underscore db so we
will have to
name it the same here too database has
been created the table name
would be users number of columns would
be three the first column would be for
the id and it will be auto incremented
now id will act as also the primary key
for this table second would be
user
name
100 would be okay
and the third would be password now as
you can see our table users has been
created with id username and password
now
let us
open
our login page now this is our login
page so to login we first need some
credentials in the database now we don't
have that kind of time to go on and
create a registration page for it too so
let us just manually add one or two
records into the database from here
phpmyadmin itself so now what we are
going to do is we are going to this
insert section
and under the username
let us type mac
and password would be one two three four
five so let's go back to browse and as
you can see we have our credentials here
map password is one two three four five
so
let's add just one other
simply learn its password would be a b c
d e
and
yes so we have both of our credentials
now now
let's go to the login page and try to
log in with the credentials that we just
created so
okay let us first enter our wrong
password to check if our error messages
are working correctly
yes absolutely so it's showing incorrect
username or password since the password
i entered was incorrect now let us leave
this username blank
enter some random password so it is
showing username is required so our
program is working perfectly now let's
enter the correct credentials
and yes so this is our home page and it
is showing hello with the username that
have logged in mac and now we have got
that logout button which will end this
session and take us back to the login
page now let's try to
login to a second account
and hello simply learn we will learn
what is rest api with php
now let's get started
now suppose you want to create a weather
app for weather forecast in your area
now to do that you have to set up
supercomputer and a satellite to monitor
the real-time weather
but i wish everyone could be that rich
now for those who cannot afford the
setup you can get the same information
from an existing web service using an
api
now an api acts as a medium between a
web service and your application which
helps you communicate your request with
the service and get a response
so in this video we'll be learning about
what is rest api
principles of rest api
how does a rest api work and finally
creating a sample rest api with the help
of php
now let's move on and see what exactly
is res api
api stands for application programming
interface
now api is a set of protocols which acts
as a medium of communication between
programs in other words it is a way two
programs talk to each other
now let us understand this with an
example
suppose you
the client go to a restaurant to eat now
here the restaurant is supposed to be
the server
how do you communicate your order to the
kitchen
here the waiter comes in the picture
now here the waiter acts as a medium
between you the client and restaurant
the server to send your request to the
kitchen and get food in return as per
requested
this is exactly what an api does
so now that we have an understanding of
api let us look at what res means in
rest api
now res stands for representational
state transfer
it is an architectural style which
defines a set of protocols of how an api
is written
now
rest follows a set of principles for the
design and development of an api
now it is a very efficient technology as
rest takes less bandwidth over similar
other technologies
so now that we know what res api is let
us move on to understanding the
principles on which a rest api is
designed
now the first principle is client server
the second stateless
third cacheable
fourth uniform interface
fifth layered system and sixth code on
demand
now let us understand these principles
one by one
client server
a res api design works on the concept
that the client and server should be
isolated from one another
and develop independently
this helps in increasing manageability
across various platforms
stateless now according to this
principle res apis should be stateless
which means calls can be made
independent of one another
also every request sent from the client
to the server must include all the info
needed to comprehend the request
cachable
this principle states that a rest api
should be able to hold cacheable data
the data in the response should be
indirectly or directly categorized as
cachable or non-cacheable
uniform interface
according to this principle there should
be a uniform interface across all
devices and platforms for the
interaction between application and
server
layered systems now res api's
architecture includes several layers
that operate together to construct a
hierarchy that helps generate a more
scalable and flexible application
now due to the rest api layered system
the application has better security as
components in each layer cannot interact
outside the subsequent layer
moreover it balances loads and offers
shared caches for stimulating
scalability
now the last code on demand now this is
optional but this principle allows for
coding to be communicated through the
api as executable code to the client to
be used within the application
we now know on what principles an api is
designed
now let us see how an api work
res api makes use of http methods to
implement various tasks based on the
client risk request
so the http method uses grid to perform
various operations on the server
crud here stands for create
read
update and delete
now in case of http methods
post method is used to create
get method to read data
put method to update it and delete
method to delete data
so i hope you have some understanding of
what risks apis are
principles on which they are designed
and how do they work
now let us move on to creating a sample
risk api with the help of php
so first let us open
the xampp
control panel
and start our apache and mysql servers
now what i am going to do is i am going
to
create
a database
for my api
let us name it api
and let us name the
table as users
it will have four columns
first one would be id
integer and it will be auto incremented
the second let us name it as name
third would be
age
and finally
email
now name would be a text and email will
also be a text
let us quickly save this
and now we have a table for us
now let us add some data into the table
so
mac
it would be 21 email would be mapped
xyz.com
now
let us create another entry
name could be simply learn
age 30
email
simply learn
xyz.com
now as you can see we have added two
rows
with the data that we just entered
now let us move on to the visual studio
code and
see
htdocs
and
let us create a new folder let's name it
api
and
open with visual studio code
let's create a new file let us name it
tutorial
dot php
and now let's start writing our
code
now first what i'm going to do is i'm
going to connect
my
database with this code
now since
the database is locally hosted
it will be local first
root
since there is no password
this field has to be empty
now
was the name of a database that is api
that is what we have to enter here
now this is a variable
to get the response from the server
for the database
okay there's something wrong
now it seems like my opening curly
braces key is not working so i had to
open
this on-screen keyboard
we don't need you
right now
now let us create
another variable named sql
now this is select this command will
select
all the data
from our table users
users
again we are going to need the curly
braces
what i am doing here is i am creating a
variable
as a counter and i am going to
give it a value of 0.
now let us create a while
loop
and in this while loop
i am going to
fetch the data
and display it in json format
uh
now we are going to write the names of
all the
rows that we created in a table
i'm just going to
copy paste it otherwise we'll have to
use this on-screen keyboard again and
again
second one was
name
agent email
now what i'm going to do is
i will
plus plus the counter
now to display it as an in json format
we have to write
json encode
with response
error message and now let us
end the
code
let us go and quickly
save our code
open our browser
go to the localhost api
this is the fold that we created
now as you can see our tutorial dot php
is visible here and when you click on it
you can see the data from the database
being
extracted
with the help of api in json format
in this video on php web development we
will learn how to create a website with
the help of php
we'll also be using html css bootstrap
and mysql in this tutorial
so get ready to create your very own
website now before we get started with
the step-by-step tutorial let me give
you a glimpse of website that i'll be
building in this video
so let me just quickly go to my browser
and type in localhost followed by the
name of the folder where i've created
the website
so i'll be making a photo gallery
website
like this
so in case you're a photographer you can
build a similar website in order to
showcase your talent
and if not you can always create your
own personal website for anything you're
passionate about
so
without any further delay
let's get right on to a tutorial
so first things first let me show you
the environment that we'll be working on
while creating a website
so we are going to be needing
two softwares that is
visual studio code that will be using as
our id the code editor
and the second one would be
xampp now zamp is a web server solution
package which we generally use in order
to manage our database and create a
local web server
you can download it from these
respective websites
since i've already download downloaded
both of these softwares so
we'll be skipping that
now
let us begin
so
after that you've installed both of the
surface just go to your
c drive
locate xampp folder
and inside the xampp folder look for
htdocs
and inside this htdocs
name a folder you can name it anything
i'll be naming it photo since i'm
creating a website regarding photos
and then right click inside this folder
and click on open the code
so this opens up our visual studio code
and as you can see our photo folder is
visible here
now also one thing that we need to do is
go back to this photo folder
right click
and create two new folders first one
would be css so it's considered a good
practice even if you're using a single
just a single css file it is considered
a good practice to create a separate css
folder inside your project folder
also
create another folder
and name it images so this is where
we'll be keeping all the images for the
website
so let us go back to visual studio code
so as you can see both of these folders
are now visible here
now
go on and click on new file
the first file that we are going to
create is index.php
and inside this index.php will be
writing the code for the main page of a
website
so let us start
first
click on an exclamation mark
and as you can see a block of code
already written is
visible here now
so
we just need to add a few things
first
let us
put the title the title would be
of course
go to
gallery
next up
we need to add a few links to our
webpage in order for it to function well
so
the first link
would be
this is a link to
link this page to
bootstrap you can also easily find it on
the internet
or you can just
type in from here
let me just go to the browser to check
if this link is working
yeah
seems fine to me
now we are going to add
another
link to it
now this link
will be for the link for a css file that
we'll be creating later on
since we'll be
putting that css file inside a css
folder
i am going to link it to
style.css
so that's it
we are done for the first part of our
code
now let's
end this head section
and
move on to the body section of our web
page
so inside this body section what we
first need is
to add a few scripts
for our page which will be responsible
for the design of our web page
so
these are the three scripts
that i'll be linking to a webpage you
can just
look and write them as it is
also keep
these three scripts at the end of your
body so
any code that will be writing inside
body will be above these three scripts
now let's
design the web page
so the first thing that we'll be needing
is a navigation bar in a web page so let
us quickly go to the browser
so instead of writing an entire big
block of code
we can just copy it from the internet
so
bootstrap provides
you with many such designs so what we
are going to do is we will type in
navbar
bootstrap
and hit enter
so as you can see
just
scroll down and as you can see this is
the navigation bar
which this code will display
also
there are different navigation bars
according to your need
along with the code
so you can just
copy any of the one you like i'm going
to be copying this one
click on copy
go back to the code and
just paste it
so now what we have here is our
navigation bar ready
so
let us go to the browser and check
how does our web page look
so after the local host what we're going
to do is we will write the name of the
folder in which we are writing a project
which is photo
well there seems to be some problem
since this
nav bar is lacking the css design let us
go back to our code and see
what went wrong
well yes this css file that we linked
here after css there is not a dot but a
flash
i think it should work fine now
well
the problem still persists
let me go back and recheck
well yeah i've made some spelling error
here
this is bootstrap not bot strap
and let us go back
reload
and yes as you can see our navigation
bar is
well and good
let's go back and make some changes to a
navigation bar the first change that i'm
going to be making is i will change the
color theme of the nav bar
to
dark note mark
go back
reload
and looks better
now
here
auto gallery
good
also
since i'll be using the drop down menu
it is absolutely up to you if you want
to use it or not since i'll be using it
i'll just change the
name
to
categories
and the three category
will be
the first is
nature photo photographs
the second would be
architecture
and the third
would be
travel
so let's go back refresh categories
nature architecture and travel so this
travel looks a little different from
this nature and architecture
so as you can notice this this line that
is dividing
this section to this section
so
let's go back so
that line
comes from this part of the code so
we'll just copy
and paste it here
looks good
now
that we're back we don't need
this
disabled
and the search bar
so i'll be removing
that
particular part of the quotes
and this form2
go back to the browser refresh
and
all of the parts of the
navigation bar that we don't need are
now have now been removed
also this link
would be
for
about section of the web page and we
will also add another section or another
link that would redirect us to the
contact part of the web page so
to do that to add another link we will
just copy this code
and paste it
and instead of about
this will be contact
go back
refresh
home contact about categories so this
categories should come before
these two
so
what we're going to do is we will just
copy this section of the code
and put it after the drop down menu
right
now go back
refresh
until we copied it instead of
cutting it
so
it's now visible twice
reload
home categories contact and above
looks perfect
so you see now that's the beauty of
building a website you don't have to
write the entire code by yourself
there are
codes already written for all these
kinds of stuff this navigation bar the
carousel that i'm going to be using in
the website the blocks of photos that we
are going to display
on the web page and a lot of design
templates you can call them have already
been written for you to use them instead
of wasting your time and writing the
entire
long blocks of code
now next up what i'm going to do is i'll
just go back
to our
photo folder
and inside this
images
i'll just
copy the images that have already
downloaded
copy
go
back
images
and paste it here
so now that we have our photos inside
the images folder
let's go back to our code and
write
a
carousel
code or just copy it from the bootstrap
go back to bootstrap
here
look for carousel
so as you can see
this is what a carousel looks like so a
big
photo
in
on the front of your web page as you
already saw when i showed you the
website
these are the different types of
carousels available on the bootstrap
website
you can use any of them
so
the first one is just a single photo
second one
is slides of photos third is slides
photos with this marking
and the final one would be all of them
combined with captions so of course
we'll be using the final one
so copy the code for the final
carousel or whichever one you like and
go back to your code
and here
after this navigation bar
paste your character code
click on save
go back
and refresh
so
since we haven't added any images here
there are none visible but you can see
this
carousel has been added to our webpage
so
let's go back and now we are going to
add the images that we just
pasted in this images folder
so in this carousel code
look for
image src so this is the location
of the image that will be displayed
so
type in images that is the name of the
folder from where you will be picking up
the images
for slash and
let me just
go back to this images architecture for
yep
so architecture four
in this alt
type in
architecture and here
is the heading so this is part of the
caption
of the
carousel so
i'll be writing arcade texture
here and i'll make this heading a little
bigger
it's three i think h3 would do
and i don't want to add any more
descriptions
if you do you can write all of that
inside this paragraph
but
i won't be so i'll just remove it from
here
i'll do the similar
with
this
so
what we're going to do is we will write
images
slash and go back
what image i'm going to be adding nature
4 would do
nature
or
type in
nature
similar
to what we did
above
h3
h3
remove this
and now
here the last one would be travel
h3
h3
and
let me just
type in the
travel 5
travel
5
and in this alt
type
travel
and we are good to go
okay let's reload
and voila so our
images are visible here with this
beautiful carousel
and you can forward them and
well
does this not look beautiful to you
so architecture
nature
and travel
but
as you can see we have some problem here
the images are way too big to fit on
this part of the screen
and it's going all the way down and this
part of the carousel is not visible on
the main page when someone opens the
website which absolutely does not look
good
so
what we're going to do for it
now to fix this what we're going to do
is we will go back to our code editor
inside the css folder
we will create the file that we linked
at the start
of our tutorial style.css and
here
just
write this code
margin
0
adding also 0
and
box sizing
would be border box
so
now to display the images
on the
just on the main page of our website
what we're going to do is we will
put a dot go back to the main index.php
and from here
copy this
name of the class carousel item
go back to style.css
paste it here carousel item
and type ing
and inside this
we will define the width
and the height of the image so the width
would be 100 percent and we are going to
keep the height at
95
we h so that it does not go beyond the
webpage
let us quickly save it go back
reload
and yes
it looks great
and
it's also visible on our screen now
now next up what we're going to do is we
will be creating different sections on
this very
webpage
for
the different categories that is nature
architecture and travel
so
go back to the code
under this
carousel code
let us start writing our first section
that would
be section
plus
so
i'll be using
my 4 and pi
4 the first
depth
so what we want is we want the text to
be in the center of the page so
the class would be text center
and
the first category is nature
now the next thing that we need to do is
we need to add the images to it
so how do we do that
also we are
not to display a single image
on a
on the entire webpage what we need is we
need to display small
three blocks of images in a row
so
we
need to create another div
class
and inside the class
we will define the column
for large
systems
for the
midburns
for the mobile devices
so
after you've written this class after
you've written this div
the images
doesn't matter the size of the screen
only
three images will be displayed on a
large and middle screen and a single
image will be dis visible when open on a
mobile phone so
all in all your website would be very
responsive to all the
devices that you will be using
let's just close it and inside this tip
what we're going to do is
we will link our
image
and
the image
would be
since this is nature
let's use nature
which image would give we have already
used in the carousel
nature 4
so let's skip that
and
put the class as
fluid
and padding
bottom padding would be three
well i think
it's done
so this is the
first section let's go to our page
refresh
so nature and our first image is also
visible here so what we need is we need
to display two more images in this row
go back
and it's now all copy and paste
just
not this part
this part of code
copy
paste
and paste
so
now
nature 2
and nature 3.
go back
refresh
okay there seems to be a problem here
let us figure out why this is happening
okay we forgot to add the
if
and without the road if the images will
not be displayed in a row
but of this
so
container
fluid
i'm using this
since
just a second
let me paste it here
yeah
and
we will create another div
named row
and
our entire code
will go inside it
and we'll paste it
let's go back and check if it changes
anything
and it does
so our images are displayed perfectly
our first section that is nature for our
categories is complete now
now next what we need to do is
i think you guessed it
we just need to
copy this section
and paste it
twice
since there are two more sections
so after the first section
in the second one would be
for
architecture
the images we need to change
architecture 1
architecture 2
and
architecture three
yeah
refresh
nature architecture
and well nature again because we did not
edit the third part of the code
so the third part of the code
will be for
travel
let us quickly
add the images
so travel to
travel 4
and i
think we use travel 5 already
so
travel 6
and go back
refresh
and travel images architecture and
nature so
half of our website is
already done guys
now
what we need to do is we need to create
two more sections for the contact and
about
so
for the contact part of the webpage
we'll be needing a form that we will
then go on and
link to a database that we'll be
creating later on
and the about section will be
responsible to
give
some information regarding the website
regarding the photographer that have
uploaded the images
so
let's go back to our code and
move on to creating another section for
the
contact
so
wait let me just copy only this section
of the code
and of course
we'll be needing a closing tag
this will be
contact
us
and
let's
create another div
class would be
50
and m
auto so
why i'm doing this is because
inside the contact will be creating a
form
where there will be columns
and to manage the width and margin of
these columns i am writing the class for
it
inside the step
we will write a form
inside the form the first thing that we
need is action
and the action for the form
will be
about
dot php this is a file that we'll be
creating later on
and the next thing is method
which will be post
let's close this
create another div
class
named form
group
okay
from group
close it
inside this
i'll write a label
that would be
name
this will be our first column input
type
text of course
let's give it a name so this is very
important so the name that you're going
to write here
should be matching should be matching
with the name in the database
and class
from
control
now
just copy
this test
and
paste
so the second section would be for
email
type will also be
email
name will also be
email
third would be for the number
let us keep the type text in case
someone wants to enter the
sud codes
and let's go back
refresh
check
contact us the fields are visible now
what we need is a submit button
so after this step
let me
create a button
type
submit
class
so this
will make the button look
green adding some
css
and
the button would be called submit
go back
refresh
submit button is here
now
let us also create a section for the
about part of the page and then we'll
move on to
making our database
so to do that what we need to do is
we'll just copy this section
for the about
place it here
close the section
and here
let's
start writing the code
the class
container
fluid so
why are we using this container fluid
class is because sometimes when you
don't use this class
the images or text from your web page
tends to
create
so you can see a scroll bar here
vertically it tends to create another
scroll bar
horizontally which we don't want
so container fluid
close this div
inside it
let me create a class
text
center
it will say the name mac
we just kept some space
and
write a paragraph
with a class of course
text
center
otherwise if the text will start from
the extreme left it would look weird
and
close it
let's add some bold
and right
let's see
i am a
passionate
photographer
interested
in
working
architecture
nature and
travel
photography
next would be
um
[Music]
full-time
freelancer
will then
experience of
five
yes
well i think this would do
refresh
oh we did not change this we'll just get
right on to it
contact us i'm a passionate photographer
interested in working architecture
nature travel photography
freelancer and all of the things that we
just written about mac
we just need to change this
to
[Music]
about
and i think we're done
yes
so
our web page is almost complete guys
now we need to do some
changes
or add some things so the first thing
that we'll be adding is
an
about.php
file
and inside this about.php file we will
be creating a connection with our
database and fetching the data from it
or sending the data from our form to the
database
so before that
let's go back
to the browser type in localhost
followed by php
my admin
click enter
but before that
you must
open xampp control panel and start the
apache server and mysql server since i
already did i did not show you the steps
so after the my sequel server has been
started you can see this phpmyadmin
panel and from here we can create
databases
so inside this phpmyadmin
click on new
and let us name our database as
graphy
click on create
now what we are going to do is we will
create a table
where the data
will be stored from our form
let us name the table as users number of
columns would be four
the first column would be
course id
which will be auto incremented
the second column would be name
type variable character
250
third is
email
also
variable character 250
and the final was our number
variable character
250
and
click on save
so as you can see the structure of our
table
the table users have been created inside
the database photography
now
we need to go back to our code
and write the code php code to connect
our form
to this database
so first variable that i'll be creating
is
con to connect
the database
since a server is locally hosted the
name of the server would be
localhost
root
that is the default
now if
connection
so this
if condition will check if the
connection is successful or not and if
successful display
connection
successful
next
also
add if the connection is not successful
we should always have an error message
connection
[Music]
failed
next what we need to do is we need to
mysql i
select
underscore
db
and inside this
we need to mention the name of our
database which is
let's just go back and recheck
for
photography
because the name is
very important if you
mess with the name the entire code goes
to win
now let me create some variables which
will fetch
the data
from the form
in order to send them to the database
so
let's keep the same names
so that we don't
create any confusion
email and of
course number
post
so now that we have our variables we
need to run
a
query
so
since we are fetching the data from the
form and inserting it into a table we
need to run a query for insert
into the name of the table that is users
and then
name
email
number
followed by
the values that
we'll be
giving them
so
notice this is the
name of the
fields that you've given in your table
and this
these values are these variables that
we've just created
so
inside it
name
second would be
email
and third would be
number
i think the query is done
now
to check if
it works
we will run another query
and i am going to add a header file here
because once you click on submit button
let me just go back
so if you click on submit button here
the page will redirect
to a different page which will just
display connection successful we don't
need that we need to stay on this page
itself so in order to do that
i am writing this header file
with the location
of
index.php
enter
and
i think we are done here
now
let's go back
and
add some details mac
mac
simply
learn.com
number would be one two three four five
six seven eight nine
zero
click on submit
go back to your database
click on browse
and if the connection would be
successful you can see the
data here
and we can
mac
email and number
that's great so
now let's move on to the final section
of the website
so
how do we make this categories
nav bar work
well it's pretty simple we just need to
redirect to a section
of a web page whenever clicked a button
so when we click on nature we need
our web page to be redirected to this
section
so
let's just go back to our code
and what we're going to be doing is we
will
create links
just a second
for every section of our webpage
so let's go back to the first section
that is
nature
and here
right
give it an id
so the id for this section
would be
nature
close the tag
cut
and
paste it here so as you can see
this id
this section of our web page is enclosed
in this id so now with this a tag we can
refer
our this section of the web page
to any button
similarly
we will add
another id here so the id would be
architecture of course
make sure the spellings are correct
put it after the section
now
go back a id
this would be
travel
okay
just
a second
cut it
paste it here
again
what i'm going to do is instead of
writing it again and again
i'll just copy it from here
place it since this is
contact us
let me just put
contact
contact here
and the section
right
and
this will be
of course
about
yes
good now what we need to do is we need
to refer these sections with the
respective ids to the buttons
go back to the navbar code on your
webpage
so here is a navbar code so inside it
you can see after every button there's a
reference you just need to
add the name of your id
do not remove this
and
architecture
travel
contact
and
about let's go back
refresh
click on categories
okay
what happened here okay no
nature
yep travel
yep
contact
about so everything works perfectly now
so while we're added let me just okay
let me first show you
rob
probably
start dot com one two three four five
five five five five
click on submit
so as you can see whenever you click on
submit
it redirects you to the front of the
webpage
i don't want that
yeah the database is working so
just go back
to the about.php
and here
we added the header location
index.php so it is redirecting
the
code to the
start of the webpage
what we need to do is we need to
redirect it to a particular section that
is contact so just add
contact in front of it
save
go back
scroll down
tony
tony after it
stack
industries.com
one two three seven seven seven seven
seven seven
click on submit
and as you can see after you click on
submit
the page does not go back to the
starting it just stays here while the
data
has been submitted
to our database
now that we have completed our website a
quick question for you guys
if you were asked to create a website
based on your interest
what would the website be about
let us know in the comment section below
now let me show you a glimpse of the
website we'll be creating which is
called techby.com
but you can obviously create a website
for the product of your choice
so let me just go to the browser
type in
localhost website and this is the
website that we'll be creating this is a
very basic website for e-commerce
services but as you can see we have
displayed the top products on the front
page of a website and here from the drop
down menu you can see laptops
and phones
so without wasting much time
let's get started
now before we begin let me tell you that
we'll be using visual studio code as the
ide our code editor
and
zam as the web server solutions package
which will be hosting a local server
server for the website
now another thing that we need to do
before beginning
is we need to go to a browser
and type in
bootstrap download
go to this website
and from here
download the bootstrap
file
this will be a compressed file you can
download it from here and i'll tell you
later what we're going to do with it
now let's go and set up a coding
environment
so let me just close this
go to c
zam folder
locate htdocs folder in it
and create
any name for your project
i'll be writing website
and inside this website what you're
going to do is
go to your downloads
now this bootstrap folder that we just
downloaded we are going to extract it
inside
that
website folder
so
let's just go back
so
we
need them outside
delete this
so as you can see we have got a css and
js folder and we'll be using this in a
website
now
let us begin
our code
so right click
open with code
now this is our visual studio code and
as you can see
our website folder is visible here and
from here
we can create a new file
so our first file would be
index dot php
now let's start our code
type in exclamation mark
and hit enter and you can see
this block of code
will be visible here
now we need to add a few things
well not a few quite a lot
first would be
title
the title would be
well
since my website is stacked by i'm going
to keep the title as take by
next what we're going to do is we are
going to add
some links
to this index.php
so these are the links for the css files
present inside this folder that we just
downloaded from bootstrap
and we'll be linking some of the files
from this folder onto our website so
that the website looks
good
now the reference would be
css this is the folder and
the file is bootstrap
dot m i n dot css
so this is the first file that we're
going to be linking
next
let's add
a script here
so this is a pretty popular script and
you can find it on the internet easily
checks
yeah
this ends a script here
let me just recheck if i typed
it correctly
yeah seems fine
now moving on
we are going to be adding another script
that would be
javascript
and
it will include boots
jquery
sorry bootstrap
i'm just going to find it bootstrap
here this ends a second script
now let us just
end
this title
and move on to the
body part of the
code
now
what do we need to produce or create
first
now the first thing that we need is a
navigation bar
so
to create a navigation bar i'll give you
a pretty easy way to do that instead of
writing a hefty big code you need to go
to your browser
since we are using bootstrap why not
take the best out of it
now type in bootstrap
navbar
go to this link navbar bootstrap
and as you can see this bootstrap
this navbar can be
accessed using this code
just copy it go back and paste it in
your body
now we'll be making a few changes to a
navigation bar according to our
e-commerce website but before that we
need to check if this navigation bar is
visible correctly on the web page now to
do that
first
let's open a zam control panel
start our apache server
and go to a browser
now to see the result of your code to
see if this code that you've just
written is
how does it look on a web page we need
to type in localhost followed by the
name of the folder that you created for
your project since the name of my folder
is website i have written website here
click on enter
and well our navigation bar looks a bit
weird
there's no designing to it now let me go
back to
the code and see what i did wrong
well yeah
we don't need this bootstrap
reboot.min.css instead
we need
just bootstrap.min.css
let's
save it go back and reload
well a navigation bar is visible
let's go back to the code
and start making some for changes
the first change that i'm going to be
making is
i will change the
color theme of this navigation bar
and yeah looks much better
now let me remove
some things
first
let's change the name to
techbuyer.com
well
second
let us let it be home
so this is the drop down i will be
changing it to
products
the first product is
laptop
the second one
once
we don't need this here
and
let me put the divider
in between
we don't need this
disabled part
either
and
neither do we need the search form
now
i want to make a few changes to the
navigation bar
so this navigation bar seems a little
thin
let me add
just a little bit of
breath to it
yep
looks good
and as you can see
laptops phones and this dividing line
now what we need to do create a front
page that is the top featured content
on the front page that will be visible
on our ecommerce website so to do that
create a div class
let us name it
and
this will be a column
div inside this
another div class
this will be for the row
and
now
just a second
yes
this will also need a class since we
want our
text
in the center of the page
and
top
products
okay
let me
just add some spaces
well
before adding those
images and the products onto a page we
need to prepare a little bit more so
before that let us just save this piece
of code and
see how does it look so it displays top
products in the center of the page
looks great
now
what we need to do before we can display
the products on this
page is we need to create a database in
where
we are going to store all the
information regarding our products
and we will fetch that data from the
database and displayed on our website
now to create the database just go back
to the xampp control panel and start the
mysql server too
now
here
type in localhost
php
myadmin
and you can see you
are now redirected to the php my admin
control panel
where you can create
different databases
so as you can see i've already created a
database named tech by
under which i have got
another table that is products
with some data here
now i'll show you how to create a
database
from scratch
now to do that we need to go to this new
part
now since we already have a text by
database let us name it something
different
e-commerce
and
create
now
we have created a database named
e-commerce and inside the e-commerce
what we need to do is we need to create
a table
let us create the table and name it
products
now our table with will mainly consist
of around
six or seven
columns and
let us keep it seven
the first would be id of course and it
will be auto incremented
the second
title of the product
which will be a variable character
2 55
price of the product
since
prices can be
in decimal
let us keep this decimal
and
the values would be 10 comma 2
next is brand name
this is variable character
100 would do
image now this
column here will contain the location of
the image on our server or
on a system since our system is the
local server
so
this will also be a variable
character 255
next would be description
this will be a text since a description
can be long
and last could be featured
all right
let us save this table
and we have a products table here
in our new database that is e-commerce
now
we need some images for this
image file for our products
now already downloaded some images
let me just
copy them
now go back to a c drive exam
what we're going to do is we're going
back to our website folder
and
we'll be creating a new folder inside
the website folder
and let us name it images
and paste your
images here
let me go back to
this visual studio code and as you can
see
our images are visible here
we'll be using them very soon
let us go back to this
and let me add an entry here
so we'll be working
with one product and once you understand
the concept you can add many more
products later on
so
the title would be
google
pixel 5
the price
65000
brand name goes google
image
now to add the path of your image what
you need to do is you need to go back
here
images now the path would be inside
website
and inside images folder so
website
images
and then followed by the name of the
image since the name for my
google phone is g pixel
i'll be writing
g
pixel dot png
make sure you do not make a mistake by
writing a name
and in the description
well i've copied some description from
the internet i will be posting
the same here
google pixel 5 5g hdb ram 128 gb
space now
inside the featured part
we'll be numbering it one and click on
go so go back to browse
and you can see
your field that you just created visible
here
so now that we have the entry
for our image for our product that is
google pixel 5 phone in our database let
us go back to the code to see how to
retrieve this
information from this database into a
code and display it on our screen
let's go back to our code
and in our code
let's go back to the
top
and here
we are going to be creating a
php
script
and inside that script
i will be
accessing the database
now
let us create a connection to the
database using mysqli
connect
and inside this what we are going to do
is we will be writing the name of
loop the server since the server is
localhost
and then
this
next would be root
now
again
mysqli
now here select
db database
and inside this
we'll be selecting a database from
the my admin panel
so what we need to do is we need to
write the variable name followed by the
name of the database that we need
information from so our the name of our
database
was
e-commerce
yep
so
e-commerce
so here we have created a connection
with the database now
let us create another file sql so
for this this variable will be accessing
all the information stored in our table
products
so
we'll be writing some
sql commands
select star that is all the details from
name of our table
products let me just recheck
products yep
and
the
feature
is equals to one
so remember that
while
creating a
entry we put this featured value as one
so
this part of the code is done now
let us go back down
where we stopped last
and
write
our
php
script
so
here
what we are going to do is we will be
creating a while loop
now inside the while loop
we will create another
variable as products
which will be equals to
my sqli
and this function is used to fetch
the data from the database
and
feature
well there's something that we missed
we did not create the variable featured
here
and
well it would have given an error
so
what featured would do is featured would
use the connection to query
the
sql command
now
go back
here
what this while loop will be doing is
this while loop
will be fetching
the data
from our table under the category of
featured number one
so
next what we're going to do is next we
will create another
div class
which would be
inside this edge for
another
php
script is equals to product
now
inside this
we are since this will be the title we
will be displaying the title from here
so what we need to do is we need to add
the title
and
close the
php script here
next
we need to display the image
so
here in this
image src we don't need to write the
path of the image since we have already
entered that into the database what we
need to do is we need to specify the
path
from where we need to fetch the image
from the database so
it's pretty simple
again the same thing
product
and as you
would have guessed it
it will
be
image was it image or images
let me just recheck
it was image
close this close the file
and
here we have retrieved our image now
protect
inside this product what we are going to
get is
the price
title so that if one would hover over
here it will display the title of the
product
and
that's it
you need to close it
set
[Music]
okay
so
yeah
looks good
next
we will display the price of the product
to do that
we will create a class
let us name it
rice
close it
rupees
we're doing it again
product
and
here
what we need to do is we need to get the
price
and close this
similarly
whatever details that we need to display
here from the database we are going to
be
accessing them
through
this script
with changing the name of the column
that we need to access
so
now that we have all this
let us
also
create a reference page
and
i'll be creating another file
details.php which will display the
details of the product
but
before that let me create a button
type button
class
button success
now the name of the button would be more
and
well
this ends here
also what we need to do is we need to
let me
just see what we need to do is we need
to
end this
while loop
and while
here
and
just
close it
so
this
div
and this div
everything's good
save
let's go back
and see if it's working
and
voila
we have our first product displayed here
on the front page of our ecommerce
website google pixel 5 the phone the
more button does not work yet
but we'll be working on it but
it feels good doesn't it
now let us go back to the code
and
see
how to create this details.php file
first
details.php and inside this file what
we're going to do is we are going to
just copy paste some part of the code
here
and
also
this part of the code
okay
and
we don't need it
now we need
one or two more things to be displayed
here so
just copy this
paste it
and paste it again let's go back to
[Music]
our localhost and what we need to
display here is
so we have already displayed the title
the price
and the image
so the things that we're left with is
the description
and the brand name
so let's go back
price is already here
just add description
and
name
was it brand name
yep brand name
description
it's good
change
class name here
okay
so
what we're going to do is we will be
refreshing this page and clicking on
more
and
well yes good the details of our product
are visible here
now let's go back and
make a little changes
so the first change would be
this so
this would be
product details
and
save
click
on there's still
a big gap
yes looks better
now
let me just
you can add some
bold or
italics
or whatever you like
in this code
um what did i do what did i do
so i've added bold in the title
let's see if it works
i'm not sure if it does
okay since it's already a heading
my bad
let me
add it here
okay
save it so this is the price
and yes price is in bold now so you can
make a few changes so look make
your description look better
and let us go back to the main page and
what we are going to do is we are going
to
create two new files for this laptops
and phones to display them separately
when we click on any drop down menu
since they don't work yet
let me show you an example to create a
file for this product laptops
and you can create
the rest yourself so
first thing that we need to do is we
need to go back to this database
into a table
and
create another entry
so the title would be
a source row
laptop
price would be
1 lakh 20 000 brand name asus
image so the image is website
images
and the name of the image is
prog asus
dot png
and
i've copied some description for the
from the internet
and
now the one thing that you need to
notice is we are going to be
keeping this featured part as
2 instead of 1
and go back to browse and you can see
the detail that we just created with the
feature number two so now go back to our
code
and create another file let us name it
raw
dot
laptops dot php
let me just see
yep i have
so
yeah i may have skipped this part so in
the drop down menu when we created a
navigation bar here it was written
this
so we need to replace this reference
with the name of the
php file that we just created that is
product
dash laptops dot php so raw
dash laptops dot php
and inside this
first thing that we need to do is copy
this code paste it here
now here change it to 2
and
drop down
top products everything looks
fine save it
since the feature number will be 2
let us go back
refresh
click on laptops
and here you can see the asus rogue
laptop visible
now let me
add another product on our feature page
that is a front page to show you how do
we display more than one product with
the same code so
go back to this database and create
another entry
let's say
hp
laptop
price would be
80 000
okay i think i just
created an entry
let me delete it
go back
hp laptop
price
80 000
brand name hp
image website
images
name of the image
that is hp underscore laptop dot png
hp underscore laptop dot png
and the description which i have copied
from the internet and in this feature we
are going to be writing one
since we are displaying this on the
front page
of our website
go back to browse here are the details
now
let's get back
we don't need to change anything just
save it
go back
and refresh
and as you can see we have our hp laptop
visible here and similarly
we can just re add products into a
database and this single piece of code
is enough to display them all
on a web
so guys these are some of the basics of
an e-commerce website you can add more
products choices more detailed
descriptions and add more designing
using css bootstrap cards
and
buy sell
sections on your website
just play along with the code and start
making your own web pages in this video
we'll discuss some of the frequently
asked questions in php interviews
now the questions are categorized in two
sections beginner and advanced questions
so without any further ado let us get
started with the beginner questions
now the most basic question
is what is php
so php stands for hypertext preprocessor
it is a server-side scripting language
that is embedded into html and is
generally used for dynamic web
development php is also a very
compatible language that is it also
works efficiently with almost 20
different databases such as mysql post
resequal etc
next question
what is a session in php
now sessions in php are used to store
data for users under a unique id which
can be then used across multiple web
pages of a website
next what is peer in php now peer
stands for php extension and application
repository
it is a framework and repository for the
reusable components focus on reusable
components of php containing code
snippets and libraries
next
is php considered a case sensitive
language so this is a very often asked
questions in interviews so php is
partially case sensitive since
variables in php are case sensitive
while functions and user defined
functions are not
next
name
different types of data types in php
so different data types in php include
integer
float string
boolean
array
object
null and finally resource so there are
total eight different data types that
exist in php
next question
how is echo different from print
now echo it can output multiple strings
at a time
while in case of print it can output
only a single string
now echo does not have a return value
while print always returns one
that is the reason that is echo is
faster because it does not have to
return a value
while it is print is slower in
comparison to echo because it always
returns a value
now
as you can see
both of these commands echo and print
are used in the exact same way
next
what are the rules for naming a variable
now there are certain rules which you
have to follow or certain
good coding practices which you have to
follow while naming a variable in your
php code so variable name must always
begin with underscore or a letter so it
cannot begin with a number or a special
character for that matter next variable
names can include numbers but not
special characters so
suppose you want to name your variable
number 1 to 3 so you can use this
variable but you cannot use number at
the read one two three since special
characters are not included
next a variable in php is declared using
this dollar sign followed by the
variable name
now as you can see this is how we
declare a variable dollar my underscore
variable you can also put a number in
between or at the end while naming a
variable just not at the start next
name some popular php frameworks so some
of the popular php frameworks include
symfony codeigniter
cake.php and laravel
moving on
how to check if a defined variable is
null or not
so is a thank function is used to check
if the defined variable has any value or
not so to use this suppose you have this
block of code in front of you so
suppose you want to check if this x
variable that you've defined is null or
not so what you do is you put the is it
function inside the if condition and it
will return true if it's
not null
while it will return false
if it is a null value since it is not
null it returns true and we can display
echo as variable x is not null while in
the case of variable y it is a null
value synth so
the if condition will be false and it
will not display anything
next
how are objects in php passed so objects
in php are always passed by value not by
reference
next question
how to display output directly to the
browser now
in cases you want to display your output
directly onto the browser while
running a piece of code you can use it
use
these special tags
to display an output directly to the
browser now as you may notice
these tags does not contain the php
written you can use them directly and
replace php with an equal to sign
followed by what you want to display
and end it with a question mark and a
closing bracket
moving on
what is defined function used for in php
now define is used to declare a constant
in php also in contrast to the variables
there's no need for a dollar sign before
declaring a constant since the value of
a constant does not change
this is how you can use the define
function to declare a constant suppose
you want to declare the value of pi
as 3.14 throughout your php code
and which cannot be changed so we can
use define for that
next question is related to this
question since
what is constant function in useful in
php then so constant function returns
the value of a constant it is not used
to define a constant but it returns the
value of a constant so
suppose you define a function constant
using this defined function and you want
to return this value
you can use this constant function for
that next
is multiple inheritance supported in php
so php only supports single level
inheritance which means a class can be
extended from only one class using the
keyword extended next
what are the different types of loops in
php so php consists of
a while loop
a do while loop a for loop and finally a
for each loop so php consists of total
for loops
next question
how to concatenate two strings in php
now
two strings can be easily concatenated
using the dot operator in php now to do
that
i'll show you with the help of a code
suppose you want to concatenate or join
these two strings str1 hello guys and
the second string would be and welcome
to simply learn and want to display
these strings together so to do that you
need to use this dot operator in echo as
you can see
this dot operator so first you write
this name of the first string
then followed by the dot operator i've
given this space
and then the next order operator because
this is also going to considered as a
string and then the third string
variable
and this is how you concatenate two
strings
next question
what is the use of function num ar
argument
now this function as you can see
is used to return the number of
arguments passed in a function so
suppose you pass a certain number of
arguments in a function and want to know
how many
values or arguments for past you can use
this function for that so suppose
in this sample code you want to know how
many arguments were passed
in this
sample function so to do that we declare
a variable number of arguments and we
will equal it to the function of number
function number argument now we will
display it
and this sample has passed three
arguments so the output would be three
moving on
what are super global variables in php
now some predefined variables in php are
known as super global variables because
they are always accessible from any
function file or class regardless of the
scope so in all in all they are globally
accessible so suppose you write a piece
of code and you declare a variable
inside it it would be a local variable
and could be accessed only in that part
of the code but in case of super global
variable they are accessible throughout
the entire code
they include global server requests post
get files enb cookie and session
moving on
how to invoke single line and multi-line
comments
now a single line comment in php can be
made using this hash followed by the
comment or
double slash followed by the comment
while in case of multi-line comments you
can use this hash star and write your
comments in multiple lines and enclose
it with a star and
slash
what i'm going to do now is i am going
to show you
the
use of these comments in actual vs code
now let us take this block of code for
example now suppose you want to add a
com single line comment after this
variable so what you will do is
you can use this double slash
this
is
a
variable
also you can use slash
this is also a
variable so this is a single line
comment now if you try to write
something else
after this in the next line it will take
it as part of the code not part of the
comment so what do you do
when you need to write multiple lines of
comment so suppose
you need to write two three lines about
this
line of code
what you'll do is you'll use a slash
star
now write the comment
this
is
displaying
simply learn
so this is a three line comment
which you can end simply
by star and a slash
this is how you write single line and
multi-line comments
now let's move on to the next question
that is name some common applications of
php so some of the
most commonly used php applications are
system functions
firm handling so php is very commonly
used to handle the forms that you see on
the web pages
cred tasks now credit tasks are create
read update and delete so when you will
be working with databases this is a very
important part of using databases that
is crud and php is used very commonly in
that
next accessing cookies variables and set
keys
and finally data encryption php provides
security through some of its frameworks
which can be used
and is used very commonly throughout a
lot of websites
so now that we have gone through the
beginner level questions that are
frequently asked in php interviews let
us now move on to the advanced level
questions
so
the first question would be how can you
execute a php script from the command
line
now a php script from a command line can
be executed
by by opening the command line
and inside the command line you have to
specify the name of the script or name
of the php file that you want to run
suppose you want to run a php underscore
script.php
so you type in the name
of the php script that you want to run
and that particular php script will be
executed
next
differentiate between a dollar variable
and double dollar variable so what is
the difference between the two
now in case of a single dollar variable
is it is a simple variable that is
simply used to store data so as we
discussed earlier
it is a variable that we defined to
store different data types such as
integer float strings etc
while
a double dollar variable is a reference
variable of variable so
this is used to reference already
existing variables now to use
or to understand how these two work
you can see this particular block of
code here now in this code what you need
to focus on is this is a simple variable
hello which contains the string welcome
to simplylearn and we have defined
another variable as where
which contains a string hello now in
this echo as you can notice what we are
doing is we are using this
also before that you need to notice is
this is the same string as the name of
this variable so first we are displaying
this
variable
and then we are referencing this
variable here so what it is doing is it
is referencing the value to another
variable so hello
variable is being referenced so
when you execute this block of php
script what you get the output is hello
since this is the variable hello and
after that what you'll
get is welcome to simply learn since
this variable is a reference to this
variable
next
differentiate between get and post
method
now
get method is used to submit form data
while post method is also used for the
same
feature
so the difference between them is get
method sends data as part of php page
url sorry web page url while a post
method sends data through http header
in get
the data since the data has been sent
through the url it is displayed in the
url of the web page so it is not secure
while in case of post method it is a
secure form of
data transfer
hence
when developing a website for some
security purposes
usually we prefer post method
next up how to connect to a database
using a php script
now suppose
if you
are asked this question in an interview
what you need to do is you need to just
write this block of code and explain it
to the interview now suppose we have a
php script
and we want to connect it to a database
what we need to do is we will create
three different
variables that is server name username
and password now
what we're going to do is we will create
another variable con that will be used
to connect it and then we'll use the
mysqli functions which will then
pass these variables to create a
connection so these variable values are
localhost username password these are
the default values now to check if the
connection is connected
what we're going to do is we will
use an if condition
if the con variable
gets and connect error we will display a
error message that is connection field
if not we will display connected
successfully
now as you can see here
these names can be the name of the
server that you're trying to connect i
have used localhost username password
for the default values you can use the
name of the database that you're trying
to connect your php script too
next up
what does final class and final method
mean in php
now a final class in php means that the
class cannot be extended
while a final method means that it
cannot be overridden
now as you can see in this block of code
we have used the final keyword for a
class and the final keyword for a
function
now suppose
this final class is
being inherited by this child class what
the program will return is an error
because once you use this final keyword
this class can not be inherited
and similarly
suppose this function is trying to be
overridden
by this part of the code
it cannot be because we have used the
final function
next question
differentiate between function
overloading and overriding
now
function overloading the same function
is used for different purposes based on
the number of arguments inside the
function while in case of function
overriding
the same name and same argument function
is used in parent and child class
respectively to change the behavior of
parent class method now let me show you
and demonstrate the difference with an
example
so
let us look at this code so suppose you
have a function named show title
which does have contain a single
parameter and displays when called upon
using this parameter displays function1
now if you want to use the same
name of the function for a different
purpose what you can do is you can
increase or change the number of
parameters inside the function that is
it now contains two parameters so when
the same function is called using two
parameters it will function differently
and display function overloading so this
is how function overloading works
next
from this piece of code we can
understand function overriding suppose
you display a function demo in a base
class and
you want to override this demo function
inside the
derived class so what you do is you make
another function with the same name
inside the derived class with some
different properties as you can see it
displays something different
now you create an object for the base
class and when you use this base class
object to call this demo function
you can use the properties of this
function here while if you create
another object that is object 2 for the
derived class and you use this object to
call upon the same demo function you are
overriding this base class demo function
that was inherited instead what it will
use is it will use the properties of the
derived demo function so that is how you
overload or override a class
function in php now let's move on to the
next question that is differentiate
between equal to equal to and triple
equal operator
so a double equal operator is generally
used to check if the value of two
operands are equal or not it is
generally used in case of conditional
statements
while a triple equals to operator
performs a type save comparison which
means that will that it will only return
true if both operands have the same type
and the same value
so
you can understand this more with this
piece of code so suppose
in this case
since they both are equal it will return
true
while in this case they both have the
same
type hence it will return true now
let us next check this equals to equal
so since they both are one and in php it
will display as true since they are
equal
while when you are type checking that is
you are checking if they're equal with
the same type and same value it will
display a false since one is an integer
and the other one is a string value
also if you check two different strings
with the type save it will also display
true
next question
how does exception handling work in php
so when an exception is thrown
code following the statement will not be
executed and php will attempt to find
the first matching catch block so if an
exception is not caught a php fatal
error will be issued with an uncaught
exception and exception can be thrown
and caught within php
so what we do is we use this try and
catch
method to
try the code and if an error occurs we
can catch
if an exception occurs we can throw it
and the catch function will catch
the exception and if doesn't we do not
include the catch function it will
result in a fatal error
next up
differentiate between require and
include
now require if a required file is not
found it will throw a fatal error and
stop the code execution while in case of
include if an essential file is not
found it will produce a warning and
still execute the remaining scripts
so as you can see both of these include
and require i use in the exact same way
with different functions next up
explain different types of errors in php
now php consists of mainly three errors
notice
warning and a fatal error now notice is
a non-critical error which means that
something minor went wrong during
execution and
a lot of times you just don't pay
attention to it
a warning is a critical error now it is
given in condition where suppose an
include function
that we just discussed in the previous
question
then to retrieve a non-existent file so
suppose you use an include function and
the file does not exist it will display
a warning and final is a fatal error so
it is a critical error resulting in
termination of the code so as we discuss
in the try and catch part of the
question
if
an exception is thrown and we do not
have a catch function for it it will
display a fatal error which will return
in termination of the code
next question
how to call a function by a reference
so ampersand sign is used to call a
function by reference now in case of
reference the actual value is modified
if the value passed inside the function
is also modified while in case of value
the
value of the original value does not
change
so this piece of code here is
an example of how you can call a
function by reference here as you can
see this ampersand sign
will call this function by reference and
any changes made in the variables here
will affect the original ones next
question
create a singleton class in php so how
do we create a singleton class in ph
before that let's have a look at what is
a singleton class now a singleton class
in php is a class that can have only one
object and hence provides only a single
point of access so in generally
generally in class you can create as
many objects as you want and it will in
turn create different access points into
that block of code
so in a singleton class you can only
create a single object hence singleton
so this piece of code as you can notice
is used to create a singleton class
now in to create a singleton class
you need to have the constructor
function private
now here
as you can see a singleton class is
created using this private construct
and it then
checks
if there's only one instance created and
if it is
it functions properly and displays
initialize only once
next question
how to encrypt a password using php so
php
can be used for encryption techniques
now the password underscore hash
function creates a hash password from
the password string using hashing
algorithm so suppose
you create a password string and enter
your password as password at the right
one two three and you put it inside the
password has hash function
so what it will generate is we are
echoing this generated hash
so what it will generate is
this so this is the
this is random it changes every time you
generate the password since it is
encrypted and
same when you pass
this password to the database using
hashing algorithm even in the database
the password will not be visible so your
data is secure
next question
mention different sorting functions for
errors in php now let us understand this
question in the vs code so php consists
of different sorting functions which you
can use to sort and given array
automatically so if you want to sort an
array in ascending order what you need
to do is use this sort function so it
will sort this array in ascending order
now if you want to sort it in descending
order
use our sort that is reverse sort
similarly suppose you want to
sort an array in terms of value in
ascending order so you need to use a
sort function that is this
so in terms of value what in terms of
value means is suppose in a given error
there are keys and values so it will
sort the array based on the values that
is this 22 27 and 37 so the array will
be the same since the values are already
sorted
now if you want to sort the array in
according to key that is this
you can use k sort that is key sort
function that is provided in php so in
case of key sort
what it does is it will sort the
array in key that is the first one would
be d
that is duke second m mac and the third
r that is raw
now
if you want to sort this
error
in descending order in terms of value
you use instead of a sort you use a
reverse sort similarly if you want to
sort an array in terms of key
in descending
you use k instead of k sort k r sort
that is k reverse sort so these are the
different sorting functions that are
inbuilt into php
moving on
what will be the output of the following
code
now
if this code is given
let me give you some time and try to
pause this video and think of what will
be the output of the following code
so the output of this code will be 21
comma 21 or 2 1 comma 2 1
how did it happen
but before that if you got it correct
congratulations
but if you want to understand it see
a is a variable that contains the value
1 while a b is a variable that is
getting the value of a variable through
reference
now we make changes in the b variable
with two
followed by this variable again which is
calling the value of a by reference so
if we make changes here we also make
changes in the value of a now if we
display this since the value of a is
already changed by reference it will
display 2 1 that is the value here and
again since the value of b is already 2
1 it will again display 2 1.
moving on
what our construct function and destruct
function in php so a constructor or
construct function is automatically
invoked when a new object of a class is
created and then can be used to
initialize value in class
so when you create a object
an object for a class a constructor
function is automatically invoked
but this can also be so it does not
contain any value when it is invoked but
you can also use this construct function
to initialize some properties to give
some properties to the class
which will act as its default properties
if nothing or
no new properties are given to the class
next is a destruct now a distract is
automatically invoked when an object of
a class is destructed suppose you end
the part of the code of a class you want
you are destroying the object when
you're ending the piece of code a
destruct function is automatically
invoked to clean up the resources
next
is how can php and javascript interact
now php and javascript can not directly
interact with each other since php is a
server-side scripting language while
javascript is a client-side language
but there is a way that these two
wonderful languages can interact with
each other so we can swap variables
since php can produce javascript code to
be implemented by the browser so yes you
can produce javascript code from php
which can then be implemented by a
browser and then it is probable to pass
those precise variables back to php
via a url
next question is
explain type hinting in php
now in php type hinting is used to
specify the expected data type that is
array object interface etc for an
argument in a function declaration
now during a function call suppose if
arguments does not match the expected
data type the run time will display an
error and the probe that is a fatal
error and the program will then
terminate now in this code here what we
are doing is we are type hinting so this
is this code is for string type hinting
and this code is for integer type
hinting now if these
particular set of functions that have
already specified the type they are
expecting does not
receive the same type of variable inside
them
the
program will return in a fatal error and
it will terminate
so
moving on to our final question of this
video
write a class so yes this is a an
assignment a kind of assignment for you
guys so what you need to do is you need
to write a class to solve the following
question which i am going to say so
implement a class named basketball we
all like basketball right so implement a
class name basketball with an attribute
named baskets so you have to create an
attribute name basket and initialize it
to 0 as the starting position
and then create a method named score now
when the score method is invoked the
baskets must increase by 1.
so let's see the solution now so this is
how you create a class that is
basketball
now
inside this class what we are going to
do is we are going to initialize the
number of baskets that is this variable
as 0 as the starting position so to do
that what we're going to do is we will
be using construct function as we
discussed to initialize some
default properties for the class so this
construct function is
used to initialize this basket's
variable to zero now suppose we do not
call this function score which is
increasing the number of baskets the
default value will be displayed as 0
every time now suppose we invoke this
core function every time a basket is
code
this will increase the number of baskets
by 1.
so this is pretty simple and this is how
you create a simple class which will
perform
the following question if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
mongodb is one of the most widely used
database management systems
so this video will explain why mongodb
is used and how to use it mongodb is
basically a document oriented nosql
database now mongodb is different from
conventional relational data models that
use rows and columns so if you wish to
learn about mongodb then you're in the
right place so what exactly is mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in august 27
2009.
mongodb replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called as documents
it offers developers the flexibility to
work with evolving data models since
it's document based mongodb allows
embedded documents arrays and represents
complex hierarchical relationships using
a single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed
as a result massive data migrations can
be ruled out
but you must be wondering when there's
something like sql why is nosql or
mongodb used
there are a few reasons why mongodb is
widely used
first up is flexibility mongodb's notion
of documents that can contain
sub-documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or ranges
next up is native aggregation native
aggregation allows its users to extract
and transform data from mongodb and
either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document-oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding and
architect can share load between
different instances and achieve both
read and write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the shard balancer
[Music]
again we have aggregation framework now
mongodb offers an extract transform and
load framework that eliminates the need
for complex data pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated
across a replica set without complicated
setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is jason now jason is widely
used across the web for front-end and
api communication and as such it's
easier when the database is also
compatible with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs
now the data is stored in the bs1 format
at the back end mongodb converts json
data into a binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data
now all of these documents are stored in
a collection
these collections hold multiple
documents and since mongodb is
schema-less the documents in one
collection need not be similar now again
these collections are stored in the
entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data
this makes fetching of data extremely
efficient when compared to other
databases now you must be wondering
where exactly mongodb can be applied or
used so let me help you with that
several areas of technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are internet of things mobile
applications real-time analysis
personalization
catalog management and content
management
now all said and done let's look at some
of the companies that use mongodb
currently
companies like toyota sap astrazeneca
adobe verizon cisco
barclays and google among others readily
deploy mongodb as their database
management system
in this video we're going to learn about
the differences between mysql and
mongodb now i'm sure you must have heard
about these database management systems
but do you exactly know what set them
apart
don't worry i'll help you in this video
first let's look at what exactly is
mongodb
now as you all know mongodb is an open
source document oriented nosql database
it is document based which means that
the data stored is represented in a
hierarchical relationship using a single
record
and also mongodb is schema free which
means there is no set schema to define
how the data is being stored in the
database
this causes lesser data migrations but
what exactly is mysql then
now mysql is an open source relational
database management system unlike
mongodb which is document oriented
mysql is a relational database system
now this uses something called as a
structured query language and this is
used to access data which is stored in
the form of rows and columns
now as mentioned earlier data here is
stored in the form of tables with rows
and columns and each data field comes
with an index representing the data in
the table
and sql is developed and maintained by
oracle
so then what exactly sets them apart so
in the coming section we look at some of
the differences between mysql and
mongodb depending on certain features
first up is the data structure
now mysql requires you to define your
tables and columns before you can store
anything and every row in a table must
have the same columns
in mongodb you just drop the data in
these documents also the data in the
mongodb database is stored in a binary
format called as bson
next up we have schema now as discussed
earlier mysql requires a set schema to
define the tables in the database now
the database administrator is requested
to define a schema which defines how the
different tables are being stored in the
database now this schema is crucial in
case of mysql
on the other hand mongodb doesn't
require a prior definition of a schema
next up is languages
mysql uses the structured query language
to perform actions on the database it is
used to retrieve data add data update
create a new data set etc
in case of mongodb
it supports a json query language to
work with data next up is foreign keys
now mysql supports the usage of foreign
keys now if you don't know what exactly
a foreign key is then sql uses foreign
keys to link one table to another now
these foreign keys make data retrieval
easy especially when there are multiple
tables interlinked with one another in
case of mongodb there's no support for
foreign keys
next up is replication
now mysql supports the master slave and
the master master replication in this
setup data set from one master database
server can be copied to other servers
in case of mongodb
it uses something called as sharding now
sharding allows partitioning of data
across multiple servers using a shard
key
don't worry if you're not able to
understand these concepts well in the
coming videos we'll explain these
concepts in detail
next up is scalability now sql database
can be scaled vertically while mongodb
can be scaled both vertically and
horizontally now horizontal scaling
means scaling by adding more machines to
your pool of resources
while vertical scaling refers to scaling
by adding more power like for example
cpu or ram
moving ahead let's look at performance
now mysql is optimized for high
performance joins across multiple tables
while mongodb is optimized for write
performance
talking about community support some of
the popular github repositories on mysql
currently are mysql js
and then there's mysql server and at the
time of writing there were about 222 000
repositories on github with 7 million
comments for mysql in case of mongodb
few popular github repositories are
mongodb slash [ __ ] and doctrine slash
mongodb and at the time of writing there
were about 177 000 repositories with
about 923 000 comments according to
google trends mysql is largely used
compared to mongodb
so now the question arises which one
should you choose
well
if your application requires multi-row
transactions
like for example an accounting system
then a relational database would be more
ideal
but if you're using mongodb then it is
more suitable for
real-time analytics content management
internet of things mobile applications
and so on
also mysql is a great choice if you have
structured data and need a traditional
relational database
in case of mongodb
it is an ideal choice if you have an
unstructured set of data so you could
pick your choice and if you're partial
towards one dbms let us know in the
comment section below as to why you like
that particular dbms in this video i'm
gonna help you install and set up
mongodb on your windows system
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here
you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under software
and
you can see that the current version is
4.4.4
and the platform is windows and make
sure that the package is msi all right
now go ahead and
press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your c drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed
and inside of it you have the server
folder and then you have the 4.4 folder
and then you have the bin folder right
so here you have the application that is
your [ __ ] and the mongod applications
both are executable files now the mongod
file or the application is the daemon
process now this is the background
process that make sure you retrieve the
data from the database access the data
so it does all the background tasks so
after the installation now you need to
create a path to this file by doing this
you don't have to always go to the bin
folder and then execute the file you can
directly execute the file on your
command prompt right so for that let's
just
go to our environment variables
but before that let's just
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path
and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
i've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on ok
and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
command prompt and run the [ __ ] file so
here you can just directly type [ __ ]
since the path has already been created
so just go ahead and say [ __ ]
[Music]
and here you can see
that your
[ __ ] server has been generated
and with this you know that your in
mongodb has been successfully installed
and your server is up and running right
so just for confirmation let's see if
there are any databases and how much
space they've occupied so you can right
now just type
show
dbs
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero
so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
all right in this particular tutorial we
will be learning what mongodb is all
about
and their advantages and some practical
demonstrations so let's get started now
so here in mongodb we would like to
discuss about what is a mobodb so as we
know the mongodb is known to be a call a
traditional
document based database
okay which stores the data in a document
okay no sequel means
it doesn't says like no to sql
instead it says not only sql that means
it is not only sql but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
heretical relationship using the single
records
that means how the records are related
with each other so that's how exactly it
represents
and it is a pure schema free environment
so that you really do not need to have
a schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema less
environment
due to that it is giving you far more
better flexibility when you talk about
completely unorganized environment
so what is nosql so the here's the idea
about a nosql so it is completely into
the non-relational database like
traditionally if you see
any non-relational database uh you talk
about
a typical nosql
uh
it's purely into the document base here
nosql does not use any tables like in
rows and columns a traditional idp base
approach if you see there they are using
a complete table structure like they
talk about columns they talk about rows
and are all about
so here
in nosql it stores the relationship data
in the documents
so the different type of nosql databases
are available like you talk about called
document based you talk about key value
base you talk about white column based
and graph based
different options are available for the
nosql but the one which we are using it
mongodb it is a purely document based
database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mobo db installation works and
the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're gonna start
working on
the first option called mongodb
installation
[Music]
okay
see mongodb installation is very simple
if you open a website and go for
this website name called
mongodb
download
if you talk about mobile db download
you're gonna see
the official website called mongodb
community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
mac os it by default detected my
platform however you can select
depends on which platform you have it
and after that you will be clicking on
this download
okay so it'll get ready for if you're
from windows
would say
in this windows
you can
select
appropriate option like two options are
available you can talk about msi or talk
about zip
my recommendation is you can stick to
the zip power portion because it won't
start any mobo db services behind the
scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want the mobility to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so
here once the mongodb is there so you
will be seeing that two files available
inside the mongodb folder inside the bin
so once you download the zip you will
find two different type of files are
available let me mention those
so inside the bin folder
you will see two files one is called
mongodb
okay another file which is available
called mobo
mobo d is to basically start a mongod
server
and the mongodb is actually the client
which will connect with the mongodb
clear so if you are in
windows environment so once you are
inside this bin folder of your
zip file
you will get the mongod so you have to
double click on this it will start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the
another binary file called mobile so it
will get start as a client
okay since i'm using the macbook here
the concept is little
different about how mongodb can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the mode is being used into your code
okay everyone so now
as we are in the
macbook so here to start mongodb we have
a very special way to start with so here
i'll start with my terminal
and here i would like to paste one very
simple command to start my mongodb
database that is called mongod
and after that you have to say hyphen
iphone db path it is a place where your
database will be starting and one more
important thing i forgot to mention
like
mongodb would not start automatically
inside your
windows machine unless
inside your c drive you have to create a
new folder name called data and under
this you have to create a new folder
name called db
because automatically when the mongod
starts it looks inside the c drive data
inside a db folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forget
whenever you're trying to use the
mongodb so you must make have you must
have this particular folder structure in
place in your local machine otherwise
this is not going to start
every time you start your mughadi
without this
location it automatically terminates so
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data db folder ready with you
however you could also change the
location of this particular folder
structure for which we will discuss it
little later on but as of now
we can see i'm giving my
location that is called iphone 7 db pass
slash data db i hit enter you can see
now my mobile db is starting now
and since it's stuck so i have to start
the new terminal now
so here
i open the another tab
and type [ __ ]
and the moment i type mobile now you can
see it is now connected with my mongodb
and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
now
to check
which other databases are available to
you so you can just type show
dbs
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there
inside your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create
new database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here
name call
use
simply db
if i say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside
let's see now you can see you say you
simply db it automatically creates
though it is not there but automatically
takes you in while creating those
okay so that means you are in current
database name called simplydb
so if you're not sure which database you
are in so you can just type dbs
or db
and it will show you that your current
database is simply db
that's it so your database is set
and we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back
in a previous videos you have seen like
how to create a database and how to
identify whether my database is there or
not so if you remember previously we
have created our database using use
keyword so if i just see my databases
which we have created is last time so
how we can check this out we can say
show
space dbs
okay so you can see we have got
database
list but we do not have any database
which we have created last time is
registered here that's quite surprising
because when we have created up a
database it should be listed here but it
is not let's do one more time i'm saying
use
sn db
and
i'm saying switch to sldb
now
when i say once again show dbs
so i still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason the reason is
according to the mongodb rule unless we
have minimum one
record or collection stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now i want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb
compared to the relational database
here the table which is actually an idb
message is called here it is called
collection
okay
db
is still called
db here
okay that means the database will be
still called database but
row
what you use this word in a traditional
rdbms here it is known as called
document
if you remember i told you like it is a
document based database so here every
single record what you try to insert it
is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document
that's what exactly the difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well
we have to basically go and create a new
collection
okay so what you can say db
dot
create
collection and here i can pass my
collection name i can say
demo
collection
so once it is done
i can see it is collection is created
in typical language i can say
the table is created and now when i try
to see same show dbs
i can see my
database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and i can see
the details are listed
when i say show dbs but there's a
another alternative option available
where you can just do that without even
saying db.create collection
well
if i want to create a collection i
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection i
can directly use this statement name
called
db
dot
db dot sl
student
dot
insert
and here
we would like to add the property like a
name
and here we can say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
db dot sl student dot
insert and i hit enter you can see the
uninserted one
and surprisingly when you try to say
press enter
you will see this sl student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line
not only create the collection for you
but also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the json based structure and due to that
it goes with the key and value appears
so db is a predefined keyword sn student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert
the record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one
property called
show
show collections when i say show
collections i can list down those number
of
collections or else i can set tables in
a typical rdbms language
which are there added in my system
so essence student in which i can see
the record is inserted so if i want to
confirm i can simply say
db dot
sl
student dot find find is a function
through which i can list down those
number of records which are added i say
find and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when i say db
dot the name call demo collection
okay db.democollection.find
i'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when i
write this command called sl student dot
insert it not only
create a new collection for me but also
insert the record into my
table also called a collection
that's where exactly it is giving you
the advantage when you want the
collections to be created along with the
data this is the way how you can really
do this
clear
but
whenever you talk about
db.create collection many people always
think about what is the significance of
having this db.create collection
look db.create collection is having its
own significance we never recommend
this technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always
bring
some restrictions
some terminology which missed out
whenever you talk about this line
so having this db.create collection you
can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use tbitor
collection in what is insert so you
might be thinking what those cappings
you're talking about let me try to brief
you
when i say db
dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name called support student
okay when i say student
so after this student
additional parameters what we can pass
is this when i say
capped
colon
true
what are we saying cap colon true so you
are enabling the capping
after that the next parameter i am going
to pass that is known as call size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose i am saying
5 2
4
and also we are saying 2 double 8 0 that
is the size of 5 mb and here we are
giving call max
colon
5.
what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever we try
to bring this create collection option
so capping true means you are enabling
the capping so what is that meaning is
it is trying to say
in this particular collection name
called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either 5
or less than 5.
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 mb
that means you're trying to say
either
by adding the total number of five
records the collective size of five
document will reach to 5 mb
okay or else the maximum number of five
documents can be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy
and they
reach to the size 5 mb and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this so that's
where exactly you can offer the capping
but this is only possible when the user
is trying to
say db.create collection this option is
not possible when you're trying to use
this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.create collection and this is what we
always recommend
well
now we would like to talk about our next
feature here
inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside the
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
mogu tv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called relational document and
second is called embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use
embedded documents because that helps
you to scale up your application without
any hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
i would say the parent record as well as
the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so
how exactly that is let's take a look
about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying db
dot
student i do not have a student
collection but i'm just telling you
db.student
dot
insert
here
we would like to add
some records what i'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number i'm just saying
uh
one two three four
you can give anything
now the next one we will talk about
caller name
this name we can say
student one
followed by
the next one i'm talking about which
course the student has registered so we
can say
course inside this course we would like
to say the course name let's say
course name
we are given the course name called
mca
okay followed by
another property called duration
okay i'm giving this duration
is called
three
years
like that
after that
this curly braces is closing
that means
see
the idea is like you see the course is
an embedded document because from course
you have a few more properties like in
course name and duration i am closing
this and starting the another
property and that is called address
okay
sorry let me remove from here and from
address
and address we can say one more curly
braces
and inside this address we can say city
i'm giving the name called what
backload
another one we are using that is called
state
let me remove this state
colon
ka
okay and the third property we're using
that is known as call country
here is saying
i that is called india
it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and outer document both are
closed
hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course and the address these two are
embedded documents and they do not have
any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
i will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
i try to say db
dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
i can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object id
and here you might have observed and
there also your option
then what exactly that id is now let me
brief you this id is nothing but a
unique primary key your mongodb has
offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it
so by default with every single document
mobodb will associate this by default
property called underscore id which you
can't even ignore
however you can override
i haven't provided any
underscore id as a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single
mongodb document if you want to override
it you can overwrite from this value to
any value because if you do not pass any
value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value
however if you want to override it you
can overwrite the value of underscore id
but you can't change the key name
let's try
with some
another record
so the same record if i try to add
let's
go i'm using call
student two
and here i'm saying one two three four
five here if i want to override it i can
just say underscore
id
colon now i can give the value call what
one zero one
this you need to remember so i'm
overriding this value with one zero one
now adding it now the records are added
now let me call find now you see this
time the records when i fetched
so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore id in a second record it is
the one which i have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore id as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons
like in composite key which you used to
do
in tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore id
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be
given to you so this is the first way of
how the insert document has been done
will be telling you the another ways
where the other documents are also added
okay so
in the previous examples you have seen
like how we can add the records
but i also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in [ __ ] tv
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for
my
emp equal to now starting with
a typical
object
like this and after that i mean
adding this
and within this
i'm adding
the first property called emp
id
colon one
after this
okay now you can see it is not
understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call
uh you know
the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now
emp id one and we just give the second
property called emp name
so
emp id uh just
remove this i just say emp id and i say
amp
name
colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here
again i'm adding another one that is
called
emp id
colon2
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
colon three
and
colon
qa
add it
okay and this curly braces is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing
and once it is done you come down
and say db
dot
new amp
dot
insert
okay and here you pass the name
of the object called my
afb
and you can see now it is telling you n
inserted three that is known called bulk
insert when you're inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay now you simply use
db
dot the collection name is what
your new emp
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object id
okay so that
is a really nice idea to have
the id to be provided
okay remember this statement
so
you understood finally how we can
add the records in a bug
going forward we will also talk about
which is related to your
update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos
okay but here that is the first thing
which you realize it how we can perform
those kind of operations in very very
simple and straightforward manner okay
everyone so now we have got three
records with us and in case if i'm
planning to perform update
on any of my records how will i do this
now so we have a predefined functions
available name called update function
let's see how this update function can
really work so we use this statement
name called db
dot
what is my collection name which is
known as call our new emp new emp
okay
dot
update
okay
so what i will do i will say db dot new
emp dot
update here
okay
now when we talk about call update we
have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
emp id what we call emp name so we say
wherever the emp id is this i want to
change what the name how can i do this
now
very simple uh
to perform this what i would like to do
now
i want to basically add few more records
to give you some more better idea
you can see now here we have a call
admin
id name
so
i just do one thing
i just change the ids
one to three i just save
four i say five
six
okay
and i
call this again the three records are
inserted now let me try to call find
now we have total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated qa
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now i want to say db
dot
new emp
dot
update
here
i would like to perform the property
like in what
[Music]
name
i think emp name
amp name
colon
i say admin
okay
so i just close that
and i use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value
here we are giving
emp name
okay what i want to do
i say wherever the name is admin change
to what
admin new
that name i want to change it
close this
close this
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
one
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here i will see
uh the value called admin new is updated
but i have one more admin called admin
it is not changed and there is something
which you need to notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update
so what mobo dv does it starts from the
top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value
and come out from the loop it doesn't
carry forward its search process for the
next level of results and that is
something which is
i really want to do that
so in case if you are planning to change
those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a call name admin
second property we have called manager
let's try to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new
underscore
manager and i want to update multiple
values so what i will do here i will put
comma and say
multi
colon
shoot
okay saying multi colon true that you
want to say hey i want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions
hit enter this time you can say it is
saying
and match to and modify to that means
two records found and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really
awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes well in our
previous examples you see like how we
can perform the update part but we have
one more beautiful feature available
inside the mongodb and that is called
how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about upset upset is a
combination of update and insert
let me try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about call update part
you see now
here
we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see what multi true we have
used
now here
this
multi true
is we're trying to update but let's talk
about something called manager 2
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there is one concept available in
call absurd absurd means if i try to
perform upset that means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
i want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi-troop
okay
so
as i can see we're using something
called name
and we're performing this update part
so in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi true
we are saying
observe true
when i say upset rule so what happened
now they say
n matched 0 and up inserted 2 and
modified with id this that means when i
try to call this find function you will
be seeing now we have a got
the another record has been added
are we clear now
as a new record
so absurd does what absurd says like if
the records are found
i will update it if it is not i will
insert it
that means if i try to call the same
thing manager to
find it is added as a new manager now if
i just try to say
uh
not manager to i will call qa
qa and here we say emp equal to new
underscore qa
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and upsorted zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey i did not find any
uh
inserted part but yes i matched one
record i found one record and the one
record is updated now
that is very very beneficial feature
when you really want to perform absurd
so that is the
advantage of upsell that is what's
called update plus insert
very
important feature then depends on the
requirement if you want to add you can
certainly add this so the way we have
tried to add this
up certain part we can also try to
perform the delete part also
okay so
also helps you to perform the delete
part and how you'll be trying to add it
now let's try to understand here in my
code if i want to perform any delete
part i have this statement name called
db
dot the option we are using it that is
called collection name emp
a new emp sorry
dot we have option number remove
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here
let's try to add the id here
or the name which you would like to
import so i want to say like
emp name admin new so we just say
name
okay
and then
name scoreboard
admin
new okay emp name add menu when i say
remove
we can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only one admin new
is available
okay now in a similar way if i try to
remove
the property call
new underscore manager
new underscore
management hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records
as i seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
now when i try to say db
dot
new emp dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now
when it comes to c
in third part we have seen update part
we have seen delete part we have seen
now it's time to basically fetch the
records
so find function we've already seen but
in find function we also have some
conditions so called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
records into your application you can
also do that let's see db
dot
new emp
dot
find
clear now so in find you can also
pick up the specific records too
like when i'm saying dot find and here
we can just say
name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with the name
called admin
because it is an emp name not a name so
let me change back to
now i can say it finds
one record
so like that you can also apply a
condition
okay enter your code
now
in a similar line if you really don't
want to offer any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
records to be
shown so you have this function
available name called
limit
to to means only two records now you can
see
though i have three records but it is
only showing me two records because i
have limit
those number of records into my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the sorting in
ascending and descending order that
answer you can also do so here rather
than saying limit we just put this
option name called sort and in this sort
on which property you want to sort it
that out you can mention
so we can just say emp name
okay and using ascending order or
descending order so we can just say
minus one let's go descending order
hit
now you can see it is showing a
descending order now if i just say
minus one if you just say one
what is showing you in an ascending
order so you can pick up the specific
property behalf on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order
so that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search
the records based on their embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added
okay that is let me try to say show
collections
i will call
sl student
and student
okay db
dot
dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records
now if you want to search the records
based on their embedded properties like
i am talking about address this is one
property name called city
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this very simple so
you say db dot
student
dot
find
okay so inside this file
you can provide the specific properties
like
my outermost property name is called
what address so we are using this option
called
address
dot
dot city
so we say
city
are we clear colon
i'm giving the city name called what
bangalore
okay
let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly braces here
hit enter and you can see now i find two
records
because both the records belong to what
[Music]
bangalore so i'm getting this
city bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which
you can
have the conditions based on less than
greater than
or whatever values you would like to
make it
is available and possible
okay
so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
i'll be clear
where the range which you would like to
consider
so those are also possible like you can
see we have this property name called
what emp id 3 and 6.
i just want to pick up only those
records whose id is greater than
what two so what i can say
db
dot
new
emp
okay
dot
find
and inside this file we can say
the property
okay so what's property we're using emp
id we're saying emp
id here
colon here we'll be using
dollar
gt gc stands for what greater than colon
we're giving the value call what one
fine
close this
run you can see you have received
three records three four and 6.
in case if i just look forward for
higher than 5
you will see only one record so greater
than
that's called gt
okay
same option if i just say lt
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay
and also you can provide
the condition so-called limit as i can
say find emp id the way we provide it so
here i will not use
less than
okay
instead i'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in emp id whatever we have taken
so let me
try to take the property call file and
here we providing emp
id and then
and we're using another curly braces and
we're using dollar in
is very important property dollar in
colon here you provide the details i'm
saying
uh inside so the properties three four
six we are saying
three
comma
six
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this
okay everyone so in our previous example
we have already seen lot many activities
this time we are trying to offer you
something very interesting feature and
that is known as call working with
indexing
see mongodb is one of the most popular
tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how
one particular
document which is huge document
in case if you would like to perform any
sort of indexing inside this how you
will be applying this
so to apply indexing into my code
let's try to understand why index is
really required without indexing
and with indexing how will be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
[Music]
okay
so what i will do is in step number one
previous records if i see i have got
uh four six three four one depends on
what early records we had it
so we had a call
new emp
so db dot
new emp
dot find
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three requires with me
now let me try to apply indexing
without indexing if i want to find a
result what outcome i'm gonna receive
so to know about
how much time it gonna be taking if if i
have a got large number of records with
me i'll be using this statement name
called db
dot the name is called new emp
dot
explain and here i will be using one
predefined functionality called
execution stats
execution starts
okay
now here after the execution stats will
be using dot
fine
we'll be using the first property here
okay
and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called emp name
colon i'm giving the name call
qa
okay let's close
okay
now when i press hit enter execution
stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was hit enter and now you
can see
a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to remember by
default
here when i try to run
it says and return one
advance one need time
total everything it is showing me
but one important thing which you will
see here
is total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now
and returned one that means one result
is returned and the total number of
documents examines three in order to
find this record
just imagine a use case here
when i say total number of documents
examine three in case if i have got
millions of records with me
that means to search the record it will
examine all the millions number of
records to search the result which
certainly gonna be taking huge amount of
time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you have no indexing is
available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default
index is applied on your underscore id
db dot
new emp
um
yeah db.ump dot
when i say db dot new emp dot get index
is a predefined function it tells me
like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore id
that's the fact because by default
index is applied on underscore id not on
the other properties
so i need to identify
which of the properties are required to
be get indexes
mongodb advantages it is supporting
multi-column indexes
and that's what exactly we would like to
see
so let's see in our next demo
now we will try to apply indexing on our
own property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say db
dot
certainly we will be talking about call
collection name call
new emp
dot
create
index
here you have to pass
two things number one
on which property you would like to
apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so i'm trying to apply on
emp
name
and i want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon one
hit enter you can see now
it is telling me
like uh
number of indexes before one and number
of indexes after two that means earlier
index was available only on one
particular property now it is apply on
two properties
if you want you can check
now you can see there's another
properties added called emp underscore
now if i try to execute a similar query
which i executed earlier
qa
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here
if i see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one see now earlier the number
of document examined were three but
since this index is applied not as
telling me the total number of document
examined is one so performance is
certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what
only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact i would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes
into your code
okay
so hope we all are clear and understood
about this concept so let's go ahead and
get this implemented into our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied
indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so
it is also a possibilities where we want
to also apply the index on other number
of properties too as you can see in our
existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new emp which
contains
two different properties one is called
emp id and second called emp name
just now we have applied index on our
emp name but in case if i want to apply
index on emp id i will be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes i'm having
this index applied on two different
properties now we would like to say db
dot
create
index
and here in this db dot create index we
can just
i will say db dot collection name so our
collection name is called new emp new
amp
dot create index
first parameter is certainly the name
of which property we are applying so
here we are saying emp id and in this
emp id we will just offer it has to be
ascending or descending let me decide
descending order
so we are saying
minus one
okay
now let's
press enter and check the status
okay now you can see earlier indexes
which we have graded that was 2 and now
it turns to 3 so it is very clear that
index is improving now let's check this
out
uh dv dot
new mp dot get indexes now we have a
total number of three indexes are
available
so you can apply index or
n number of columns if you want
okay at the same time
the way we have created the index in
case if i want to drop an index
so we can also drop so what we can do db
dot
new emp
dot
drop index
draw
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which
index so you should have that particular
index name
okay so here
we are providing my index name so it
should not be uh i would say the
traditional name called emp id no it has
to be emp id
underscore minus one or
emp name underscore one so this should
be the name
i'm saying emp
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the emp name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say emp name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was
three
okay one
okay
now you can see we have a call emp id
and underscore id
so
now we have
only two indexes left
there's no emp name anymore this is how
exactly you can drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in a previous examples of mobile db you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen how to utilize
uh indexing into our code now in our
next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation works see in mobodb
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply
some very simple code snippets into your
ongoing
uh i would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate db and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of records are
already added now
if i just want to apply aggregation now
i would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is
see ideally when you talk about call
aggregation
okay so aggregation is nothing but a
call aggregate like rdbms if you see
medical aggregation there so the unix
command like you talk about shell
pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of functionalities are
available which we will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things
now here let me try to bring some of the
important well-known
i would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use the
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select specific
specific fields
dollar project is designed to select
what specific fields from the collection
we used to talk about call what
dollar match
the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it does the
actual aggregation
fine we talk about call dollar
sort
okay it basically sort the document
okay like that there's so many
operations that are available that you
will see one by one in our aggregation
behavior now my first example the one
which i want to execute i have a call
student record with me which contains a
student name okay the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student is
appeared
now here my first requirement is we want
to filter
data based on a section a because
students belong to the different
sections
as you can see now it is they belong to
the different section section a b c d
so i just want to
filter the data based on a section a
okay so for filter out i would like to
use dollar match
let's see how it works so i just would
like to filter out those students who
belong to the section a
so how we would like to use it now i
will say
db
dot
student dot
aggregate
and inside this we would like to use
this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this
i would like to use another curly braces
can i say
section
a
okay can i close this
close this
close the square bracket close this
okay so db dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is known as aggregate
functionality section a hit enter and
you can see now it lists down all those
students who belong to the section a
okay very simple and straightforward
example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records where the section is a
and we are using and operator
marks is greater than 80. there are so
many students over different marks like
70 19 and whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now
remember not only the section a
but also marks were greater than 80.
so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we are starting
this curly braces
okay
so
after this match we would like to bring
and
we say dollar
and
and again colon
again we are starting this square
bracket now
okay we talk about what
section a
number one
and uh after the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say marks
colon and once again
they would like to start
curly braces and here we use
dollar
gt that is called what
a greater than colon
80
okay all are closed
so you see like here we ever got this
square bracket in noun brackets
so what else is left
so we have a call 80 we are using
another curly braces needs to be closed
here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
again curly braces
again
square bracket
again round brackets
okay
let's see where it has gone wrong
so we're using this
db.student.aggregate we'll use this
yeah square bracket
then curly braces then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces
and we have a call and operator
after this and we have a call
this
square bracket then curly braces section
a
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks
colon
dollar gt
okay and we are using what
colon 80
after that we are closing this
and using two more curly braces square
bracket in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that so
db.student.aggregate and like this it
will be able to get it now okay so in a
previous example that was the only
missing point was after this
uh
this dollar match we didn't apply this
curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and i
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this i would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now i
just would like to bring selective
fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything i'm getting it
so i really don't want to bring all the
properties from this
document i would like to selectively
take specific property
so
uh let's talk about how we can use this
so we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select
the specific record
so
i just use this statement name called db
dot
student
okay dot
we are using it now after that
now square bracket
and curly braces
now we are trying to say
dollar
project
what we would like to use dollar
project and calling we are trying to use
student name
okay colon
okay remember one thing one means i want
those zero means i don't want so
whichever property will be enabling it
by giving the one as a digit that means
it is
it is expected to be displayed so i'm
saying one
comma i'm saying section
colon
one okay and i'm also
looking forward for marks
color one
that's it so now
you can see now i am once again picking
up only those
like student section and marks now if i
go back and
remove some properties like
i only want
student and section you can see i have
only student and sections
are used
here if i just use this statement name
call
underscore
id colon 0
now you can see only
the names
and sections are visible id is not
because i really don't want id by
default id is shown but if i says is 0
that means the id will not be visible
here so like that you can select
the columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way another
thing i would like to use
what if we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from student once
again we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my
implementation if you see the previous
one what we have used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this dollar match
this is the curly braces i'm giving
section
a
okay section colon a and after this i'll
close this
okay
and close this again
again i'm opening it up
by using this option called
project
dollar
project we're picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again
and say
student name
student name
colon we're using one
comma
section colon one
and
one
marks colon one and now
closing this
now you can see i got those so the
requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from student
collection where the section is a
so you are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection
gives you lot many opportunities
which you can utilize it for your own
and also it comes with lot many
predefined functions like in some avgn
and all
so let's talk about those
functionalities too
so this is the first thing which we have
seen aggregations are taking place
now in case if you would like to perform
the group like if i want to find out the
total marks
group by
okay
section like each and every section i
would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how do i basically
do that
so let's try to get this example also
so here
let me try to go back
and we will not be using match here
because i would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly braces
we want to use
dollar
group
okay that is called group by in rdb is
how you use it
here we use this curly braces
again
here we are passing this underscore id
okay you have to provide underscore id
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar id whenever
you're trying to talk about group this
is a compulsory field you need to have
it
after that
i'm using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing
and here we are using what
total marks
colon
here curly braces
again
dollar
sum okay colon on which we have i want
to use it mark so i can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a javascript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now
section wide i'm able to get all the
marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of records
so hope you are clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
hope you are basically taking this
marks in my application fine so
we are clear about how we are picking
that up but what in case if i would like
to take a marks for the specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but the only thing is
what we'll be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get
the all the section marks but if you
would like to bring it only for the
specific section we know it very well
what we need to do so here
before i talk about call dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar
match
okay and here we are using this
option called section a
sorry
here
in dollar match we are giving this call
section
conan
here we're giving
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section you're able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay so that's where exactly would like
to perform and there's another option
like in case if you would like to
perform an average suppose if you want
to
fetch the count of student in each
section and total marks
and average marks as well as so total
marks as well as the average marks you
want to get it so how are you able to
take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also
into our code how we are taking call
group underscore id section talking
about section
total marks with the sum
we are also using this after that we can
also use the average
okay
so
this is we have taken
group underscore id sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say sum marks
after that
we can just put curly braces
and we can just use
count
okay
and
after this we'll be using this colon
curly braces and use
dollar
sum
okay
colon one
okay and after that i'll put
comma here
and we use
average
and inside this average i will use
in curly braces we can say
dollar
avg
okay
colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly braces is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and round brackets
and now you can see you got the average
markings
in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobile tv that
really create a difference of how
the
aggregation changes the way how you
react
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
aggregation it's time to talk about like
how
when it works with mobile db mobile db
is properly known for
i will say
for replication that is called high
availability and that feature comes by
default with mongodb you really don't
need
to install any software for this because
it is a built-in feature for the mongodb
so when you download that it
comes along with this so no additional
uh configuration setup is really
required when it comes to the mongodb
part
okay so let's get started and talk about
how mobo db
can offer the replication see the idea
behind the replication is what
the idea behind the application is like
you are replicating it
okay
so when you talk about replication you
are replicating your data to where the
multiple child so here in mobile db we
have one concept available
okay that is known as call master
okay and
slaves
okay master is one and there will be
multiple slaves
okay so these slaves where your records
are actually stored
and this is a master which will be
responsible
to replicate the data to all its childs
when the request comes due to that
in case if one particular
node
fails so automatically the data will be
taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and node slave process so to make this
possible to be a very simple option
available
in mongodb we have one concept like
called mongodb atlas so there we can go
and get our cluster ready so here we
start with the concept name called [ __ ]
db atlas
let's search for mobile db atlas and
here i see mobodb atlas database as a
service see this is a free tool
it's the cloud environment where you
really don't need to install mobo db in
your local machine it is a cloud-based
mongodb support
which is free to use with a limited
amount of space but yes for the testing
purpose it is the best suitable
so i can start with the start free or
else i can say the login here
okay from there onwards i can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is the place from where you can
start working on your cluster
see as i've told you like initially when
you will be working on this
mobile tv it will ask you
to create a cluster
initially
okay since i already have a cluster with
me
okay so
i really don't need to create it and as
a free
tier it will not
allow me to have more than one cluster
setup ready so if i say create a new
cluster
okay and i say
by default aws
okay and let me close on this
notification aws you can select any
other cloud provider
and
html cloud backup cluster name you can
see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour reason being because i
already have a cluster with me hence
more than one cluster is not allowed in
a free tier cluster so i have to cancel
this
but
you can go and create a cluster
the way it was offered there so if you
want to create you can just go ahead and
do nothing just select by default aws
select your location
okay give the name of the cluster you
want to give anything you can give it
here otherwise let it be the by default
name cluster and say create cluster it
will take a while minimum
two to three minutes depends on
the availability it creates a cluster
for you
and your cluster once it is ready it
looks like that
okay
so here in this application you have to
go back and understand what is there in
a crystal when you click on cluster zero
you can see now
here we have a got
three nodes available one is called
primary node which is called master as i
suggested earlier
and now we have a call slaves
automatically when the clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary two will be
secondary
based on your package whichever you have
taken it you can increase the number of
nodes later on but as a free i'm gonna
get or i will be receiving total number
of three nodes available here
so records whichever will be stored it
will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary nodes and from the primary
i can insert the record and secondaries
i can read the records remember you
can't insert the records into the
secondary so you can only insert a
record only in your
primary record secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you no whatever no data
available no data available
nothing is there because i haven't
stored any records as such
so i just go back to my cluster
so initially
i would like to go back and
create few things now okay i would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the clusters
because when unique cluster is created
clear now so in that point of time no
setting is configured you have to do few
settings now
first setting is you have to put it
remember the steps
first step will be your network access
so in network access you have to go
and you have to say add ip address
and in this ad ip address you have to
select this option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those ip addresses will be
whitelisted
otherwise what you can do you can see
here in my options i have given
0.0.0 that means all ip addresses are
acceptable
so all ip addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third-party
locations
next you will talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user there are
already some new users are created but
it is recommended that you to go and
create a new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user
so by default it is username and
password is given
so you can go back and create a new user
when i say add user
you can give
the username as well as the password as
per your own convenience so new user i'm
going to create it is called
sl
okay
user
and here we're giving call
uh admin
123
so sl user admin 123
remember this will be the username and
password i'm saying add user
new user is automatically added sl user
admin one two three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement okay network access database
access it will ask you
like you want to create a new database
so i just go back to my project zero
will be on an option called collections
you have to go back and create a new
collection
here now it is
retrieving the list of databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there mrdp is one of the
database which is there
demo db is there lot many databases are
there so you can go back and create some
new database and connect through
so i just create database i already have
a simply learn db with me
user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a databasing correction is
very easy if i give you the quick demo i
say create database
give the collection name called
sl demo
okay and give the username call
amp
slw employee like say create
now you can see sldm create it is there
with me
so there is no record right now
and once it is there ready so remember
sldm
and employee i'll go back to my
code again project zero
and from here i can say connect
because i want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there so you want to connect it
through so to connect it through here
very simple option available you can
just click on this
connect option multiple options are
there through mobile share connect your
third party application of the mongodb
compass so
since i already have a [ __ ] shell with
me
so mac os i have this mac os with me
so you can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since i have this mac
os
i'm selecting this line
but i need to replace with this
you can see this username
okay
and you have to give the username here
i'll i'll selected this i open my
terminal
okay and this is i'm just closing this
and opening up
another terminal here
since i want to correct for the [ __ ]
shell now
so
what i need to do here in this
i'll just paste that
the command which i have it now
username is
you remember i told you
you call
some users which you have already
created
let's check
here
sl user
i say
that's a user
i hit enter
it lasts me the password so i've given
the password admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me
to this
particular
see
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your shard cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly i have
it with me
so i'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there if i just want to go
back and say
show
show collections
so i can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so
it's up to you now
by default collection which is their
employee so i can say db
dot
employee dot
insert
and now here we can just add
name
okay
now you can see
some exception is raised
so
you understand
now you can see the records are added
into my primary cluster so if i just go
back and
go back to my project 0 where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
[Music]
sl demo
employee
loading the documents
so it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly
you see
the records will be stored
okay
so that's where exactly it works fine
for all of you
so we have this
record
okay so when i say
show collection so we have a call
employee
and i say dv dot
employee dot
fine
so i can see we have got new collection
name called
[Music]
this is added right now
okay so like this you have got
the first connection established and the
records has been inserted in this
particular tutorial we will help you to
connect your mongodb
with the front end that is called python
as we know it very well about the
popularity of python in last recent
years it is growing like anything so we
thought why not to offer you
this connectivity where you can have
the mongodb
not in a local environment but in a
cloud environment so here we will tell
you how to create the mongodb complete
environment of cluster in your cloud
and we can have this connectivity with
our python which is running local to my
system so i show you what few important
things
one by one
so
why python mongodb
we understand mongodb is one of the most
important
database which is so called document
based database available in market and
it is fantastic phenomenal in terms of
speed and the reliability
it is purely
called nosql database
okay and helps you to go schema less
now python is one of the most commonly
user-friendly programming language for
creating a complete web-based framework
so it offers you huge amount of
libraries with flexibility of connecting
wide variety of applications
so we would like to give you the idea of
like how python and mongodb works
together
okay
so you can
use both the
products together to develop
different varieties of
applications which can suits to
different type of ideas now here we have
one of the very very popular tool
available name called pi [ __ ]
so pi [ __ ] is actually the python
library which is a kind of a driver
through which you will be able to
connect with your mongodb and perform
basic operations whichever you expect
okay so let's go ahead and start working
on those demos okay
so we will start with
creating a mongodb environment with
cluster and one of the very very popular
tool that is known as called mongodb
atlas so we'll be opening our website
and go here and talk about call
mongodb
atlas
i search for mongodb atlas that is
basically the mongodb
where i called database as a service
i'll be selecting the first option
and go to the start free because it's
gonna offer you by default some 500 db
of free space
i say sign up with google
going ahead and selecting this
okay i say accept
and say
submit
okay so it is starting up now
it will ask you about a few things i
would rather say to select escape
and continue
well it will ask you about which
environment you would like to take so
i like to take this shared cluster i say
create cluster
now here it will take a while to get
yourself ready for you can see it is
offering the sandbox off having five
columbia free space
and this mongodb
no backup that is the by default
customer name you can give the name of
the cluster if you want but let it be by
default cluster zero i'm saying create
cluster
so my cluster is being ready so it will
take a while to get your cluster
set up
so just wait till the timer cluster is
getting ready so i tell you what this
cluster is going to give you
by default two child and one parent so
called a one master and two
child nodes where your cluster will get
ready
so
you really don't need to set up any kind
of cluster in your local environment and
that is the best environment i would
suggest for
most of your development where your time
reduced
there will be no software requirement
because sometimes version 2 version
changes
and you can get all the benefits of
clusters
so we're just waiting till the time the
cluster is getting
ready so once the cluster is ready you
will be seeing some options where
will help you to create the clusters in
your upcoming demos
so friends your cluster is now ready
you can see now in this cluster you have
got this
environment
so in this environment you will see
there are some options they have given
you one by one
build up your cluster create a first
database user add an ip address multiple
options are telling you now so how to
set up so the first build of the cluster
which we have anyways done next is
called create your first database user
so select this
so it will highlight this area now you
can say like database access
and
i'm going to create a first new database
user and new database user
given that it is a name for admin
let's keep very simple username and
password admin
one two three so admin admin one two
three
yeah same
and say add user
now you can see
the user is
created now let's go back to the next
option
it's telling me the network access now
go here
and say
sorry
now say add ip address
and
i'll say allow access from anywhere so
that i can take it from anywhere
i say confirm
now it is telling me about the progress
i select this
and tell me about which type of
collections you want
okay so i select this
and inside this i'll be selecting this
called collections
okay
and uh it's getting
ready
what is giving me some options
well two options that will give you load
sample data set add my own data i'll say
add my own data give the database name
sl demo
give the collection name emp or employee
remember
database name sl demo or i can better
give the name called srdb
sldb and employ i say create
that is getting ready okay so my
database and table is ready
that's it
so i think
we are all set
with this environment
okay
well once it is ready your collection is
also ready i'll go back and click on my
project zero
and here
yeah so once it is there then i'll be
clicking on this option call
connect
now it will give me the multiple options
how to connect
so it will say correct with the [ __ ]
shell or it will say connect with your
application correct using [ __ ] compose
i'll select
the python
python version
3.11 or later so certainly i'll be using
those version only
okay and
in this i'm having this
so i will be using this to connect with
my back end
so that's how exactly you have
the setup of mongodb cluster
everyone so we are all ready now with
our
setup
cluster we have already created earlier
you remember about we have taken python
3.11 or later
so here if i just go back and check
i have a god three point eight point six
which is python three version which is
available so you can select based on
whichever we have it let's say three
point one one or later we can say three
point
six or later so there'll be no
much difference if i just see
even if i just talk about 3.4 there's
some change but here's 3.6 or later
it is same so i have a 3.8.5
okay
so i can use the same option
so here in my
vs core editor i am using for my
development so here is a simple demo dot
pi i have used welcome to check if it is
working fine so yes it is working fine
i'll start working with my first program
with mongodb so i just go back and say
demo
py or i can say uh
py
demo
dot py
okay
and here if i want to go back and start
working on the development remember one
thing we need
first dependency called pi [ __ ]
okay what i need pi men [ __ ] and for
this we have already installed this
dependency here
sometime back this is how you installed
okay so we have this statement name
called what pip installed by mongol
that is the first dependency which you
need to download in order to work with
this
okay
so
that's what we have taken this is
installed by [ __ ] so if you just see
you can go back and start
developing this statement
okay so let's go back and start working
on this
step number one you need to always say
import
number one the one dependence which
you've installed is called buy [ __ ]
so
as you can just say p by mo ngo
that is the dependency we have recently
imported
from
okay let me go back and search from next
point so import pymongo
import
[ __ ] client
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
after that we would like to go back and
use the cluster
so we say cluster
equal to
[ __ ] client and here i'll be passing
the complete values the one which we
have taken
so this complete line i just take it
go back
and here
i'm pasting it
now here
i have to basically replace this
password with admin one two three
okay and we are all set
okay
now
once it is ready
we can go ahead and define db
equal to
cluster
and provide which database you're
talking about
okay so you remember about we had a
database which was available to us that
is known as call
sltb so i can just use the same sltp
there
and accordingly i can use
which collection i'm connecting it to so
accordingly i can go back and insert a
record okay everybody so i can see i
have got this
file with me going forward i have to
tell
see this is what exactly the connection
url you've received now you define which
database you're working on
let me say tp equal to
cluster and we have to provide in
double quotes the database name called
sltp if you remember we have used this
after that we have to mention which
collection it was so
collection
equal to
db and here we just give the name call
employee
that was our collection name
so once it is ready then i have to
basically perform some insert operation
so i just say post
okay it's just a name equal to
and here
we just provide the properties
like i would say name
so
you know to the json-based database so i
can just use the name
i say
armor
and once again i can just say
email
and
say i'm anthonymail.com
that's it so this is just the data which
i have now i want to insert so i can
certainly say
collection dot because i want to insert
only one record you can see i have open
functions coming up
collections dot insert one and plus
post
is in parameter now we are all done
let's try to run this
so i'll be running this with python 3
py mobile.py
hit enter
now it's done let's confirm
here into my code i will just go back
and check
here inside my
applications i can just go back to my
collections
and in employee
yeah there we go we have got some
records coming up here
okay so these records are nothing but
the one which we have recently inserted
in our application
okay
so fantastic so first example is working
perfectly fine how we can have the
records coming from the python and
insert it there
like that i can have as my number of
records i can add it
so how we can basically add if i want to
add more than one records
let's see this now here and in case if i
want to add more than one records so i
can just use call post one
i copy this url
and paste it below
and i say pause tool
i say
i'm saying
email
um one two at the rightmail.com and
rather than saying insert one
i can use
insert many and inside this i'll be
using this
square brackets
and pass
post
post one corner
post two
that's it okay so let's change the
little name because it's already there
let's insert
yep records are inserted let me verify
once again
by refreshing it
well now we have a total number of three
records are available
now there we go so records are added
perfect so like this you can have
as my number of records you can
basically add it in a similar one the
way we have basically used this i can
also perform
the search part too
okay so in case if you want to perform
the search part we have a very simple
statement available with us what
i'll go here
the way we have added this so
in this i'll just
these records which are added inside my
application i would not execute this
rather
i would like to go back and say
now they are basically commented now
and
in fact i would like to use this also
okay i will go here
and
find results
results equal to
same collection
dot
find if i want to find a name we can
just use
curly braces
name
colon
[Music]
okay
so let me say print
and pass
results
okay let's run this
okay so it'll print what
the results for me
okay
so
it is just printing what the cursor
object for me saying hey this is what a
record is available to me we can also
change in case if we do not think the
correct result is coming up we can also
go back and
we can use some alternative option that
is called for
okay so what we can do let's take a look
here
we can use for
with this for i can say result
okay in
results
and
print this result
that could be one option through which
you can get the details with you
okay
so what you can do you can run this code
again
i forgot to put this
semicolon here
or
we need to check
well that was my
requirement was so i'm having this
let's try to run this
but i got my result and this is what the
detail which i have available to me
so
very simple how you can basically find a
record and how you can basically
retrieve the records at the same time if
you want to have the specific field
rather than all the fields so here in my
code can this result
okay you can just put the square bracket
and tell which field you really want it
now suppose if you just want id or else
if you want name
you can basically pick that up
okay so if i just want that
id
the only id is printed that's it
okay everyone so you have seen like in
my previous code how we were basically
trying to fetch all the records we were
using this file
now in a similar line you can also have
the option available because see when we
used to talk about confine it gets me a
lot many records
fine and because of that we were using
this loop
but in case if you want to fetch the
individual records
i'll be clear so in such cases you
really do not want to use fine
you can just
use find one
so what you can do is rather than using
find
i can also use one more option called
find one and for which
i can come back
just remove this all
yeah so here in this case rather than
using this file i can use fine
underscore you can see this option
called file one here we talk about
which are the properties you want to
skip and which of the properties you
want
so i can just use this option called
underscore
idle
okay colon
zero okay i just remove this
undersquared zero and here
just print what results
that's it let's run
so that will try to fetch some of the
records for you because if you do not
have that id which you overwritten it
will certainly not found it depends on
what you would like to take
so if i just say
is having some issues but no problem but
you know it very well how it basically
takes
now in a similar line we would like to
also perform one more activity
to talk about delete
so for which what i will do is this i
just want to uncomment it
okay and i would like to insert some
records here
so here i want to add the id by my own
with name
so we already have this name
email
i have it i would like to use underscore
id
okay
so
we have this property underscore id
colon
101
okay
comma like this
copy the same
using it here
and this time
i'm using
one zero two
name and everything
it'll be taken let me say
user1
here we try to say
user
2
okay
so collections.many result file one i'm
just deleting it all
and let's try to
execute it first
okay so it's executed going back
okay so i have some records with ide one
zero one and one zero two
now here
i just delete this
and perform some actions here
here we say
results
equal to
collection
dot
delete
see the options are available delete one
and delete money it totally depends on
what you really want
okay so if i just talk about called
delete one it will be only deleting one
record delete money means where are the
matching records that are available to
delete it
fine so i'm just using this option
called delete many
okay wherever the property names are
matched cause quite possible name
sometimes match or whatever it is just
then delete many
so the option is up to you now for you
want so the selected name you have to
offer it
whether you want to match it with the
name or whether you want to match it
with the email or whatever it is
so that will be offering it but there's
also one option available where you
would like to delete everything
are we clear so if you're planning to
delete it everything what you can do you
can just leave it as a blank and try to
run this
so collection
dot delete
underscore remaining
let's check
great all records are deleted so as i
told you earlier also so delete many
means what it will delete all the
records whichever are present in your
code now
clear in a similar one if i want to
perform insert
so you remember about we have an option
called what
insert many
and here
we would like to pass
post one
host two let's execute
so it'll add
the records inside this
okay
and next time what i want to perform
after adding this record i would like to
perform
the update part
okay
so
what i really wanted my update let's
take a look update means certain
properties i'm looking forward to be get
updated
okay
so
in case if i want to check the record
has to be updated i would first go and
check
whether the record does exist or not
yeah we have two names user one and user
two let's go back and update bar
here
i just
save collections
okay dot
update one
update you can see
update one here very simple
functionality
here you will go
and tell which id would like to perform
an update
by saying underscore id
colon
which i do you want to consider i'm
saying one zero one
okay
and what else
so i just use another curly braces and i
say
sorry
dollar
set
and after this
i use this colon
use the curly braces
name
okay and
use whatever you want to use it
so suppose there's a user one i'm saying
users
one two three
okay
let's see
it is loading and you can see the record
user 1v3 is updated
perfect
so
your code is absolutely working fine so
you talk about either insert you talk
about what
update you talk about anything it works
so insert update one
delete one
insert one as the name suggests they'll
be taking care about inserting updating
and deleting one one records but the
moment you use many they'll be
performing multiple records so this is a
very simple way like how the python will
connect with your mongodb now with that
we have come to an end of this session
on php and mongodb if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you need
the resources that we used in this
session then please feel free to let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you